然后晚上直接冲进了我们的直播间
然后那个首先的话按照我们的惯例
首先跟同学们回答一些来自于我们社区的问题
那首先那个同学很多同学问我们说
上一节课布置的作业
马上这节课要布置新的作业了
那我们上一节课作业还要不要继续去教
那实际上的话呢就是说呃我们考虑到很多同学
因为很多同学做的速度非常的快
当然也有很多同学的话呢
还要花很多的时间
慢慢熟悉我们小引擎的代码和东西
所以呢我们决定还是把这课程的时间延长一点
另外一点的话就是我们也发现在B站上
因为B站特别好嘛
就是视频会一直放在那
会不断的新同学进入到我们的社区
然后呢大家有的人还在还在补上前面的课程
所以等到新的课程能能够做的时候
可能还需要一点时间
所以的话呢我们决定暂时的话
还是把这个新的课程的这个啊
这个上一节课的作业的这个时间继续往后延
然后具体什么时候我们能够so that dine的话呢
我们在争取在后面一节课程跟大家
或者在那个微信上跟大家在同步
反正简单来讲的话
我们尽可能把这件事情变得flexible一点
因为确实照顾到
就是这个课程现在的周期已经非常长
长达接近三四个月
所以每个同学进入的时间啊
水平都有波动
那我们尽可能让大家都能兼容的了
那么另外一个的话呢也回答一下同学们的问题
其实这个问题蛮有意思的
我们选了几个比较有意思的问题
就有同学问我们说
哎你们为什么不用像那个什么FBX啊
这些公开的这些格式啊
对吧
那么其实的话呢
首先就是这些格式是直接来自DCC软件了
包括这些这些格式呢
现在有很多人在用
那么但是的话呢
我们当时其实最核心的一个考虑这两件事情
第一个就是我们尽可能让那个PICO引擎
越简单越好
如果我要支持FBX格式的话
大家如果研究一下
就是FBX格式是非常成熟丰富和完善的
那我们就需要接入一个完整的
迪斯萨斯第三方库
然后呢去让大家去
这个就是处理这个FBX文件的格式
包括这些数据读进来之后
我们还在做一部比较复杂的转换
当时我们在想
就是说如何让同学们能够快速的理解像反射呀
引擎的基础
数据流的架构啊等等这些东西
包括我们考虑的
就是在真正的商业级引擎里面的话呢
我们一般不会直接用这种啊TCC的格式
因为IP格式虽然非常好
作业文件就是在不同的工作室啊
或者是那个工序之间传输
文件是个很好的
中间我们叫intermedia format
但是呢它并不是一个效率或者引擎
friendly的这么一个格式
因为对于真正的游戏来讲的话
我们的这个数据格式要求它的效率
比如它的packaging
它可以加密
它可以流式传输
它可以那个就是说对可以留市场等等
这些要求是非常的高
那么所以的话呢
我们就想说让同学们一上来就能够习惯
或者适应这种
就是说诶小就是customize the fireformat
而且能够你的schema系统
能够和这些东西能够连接起来的
这样的一个设计
所以我们相当于用一个最简单的格式
把这套机制教给大家
因为从schema反射到你的custom format
它是一个完整的一个组合关系
那么另外一个同学没人问我一个问题
就说诶你们为什么没有用那个
在Mac版本中没有用meta
而是直接用了这个就是那个那个model的VK
这个东西放在上面
就是其实这个原因很简单
首先我们已经被同学们狂喷了
说你们为什么要van对吧
因为相比open gl的话
van实际上复杂很多
我也跟大家解释过
就是说呃当时我们的考虑是说
让同学们直接接触现代的这个GPU的一些
API的一些结构
因为它真的是非常啊接近于driver的这个写法
效率是最高的
也是最具有工业化的这样一个基础的一个东西
那么welcome本身已经非常复杂了
那这个时候我如果再去上一个DX12版本
再去上一个metal的版本
那肯定是最好的
就是说它肯定是性能最好
也是最符合各个平台的设定
但是首先的话我们开发团队的话
工作量会非常的大
因为同时要支持三个版本
大家想象一下
我们是一个就是开源小引擎
其实同学们都是用业余时间在写
另外一个的话呢
就是同学们掌握和学习起来的话
可能门槛会更高
要理解
比如说他的第一层的这个就是RH这一层对吧
抽象的更好
然后接下来的话要针对不同的平台
我们用不同的版本
所以的话基于这个考虑的话呢
我们一上来说OK统一的用motion一个版本
其他的平台搞不定的话
我就强行的用一个中间件把它给转过去对吧
就像那个我们现在在那个
其实在Mac上还是metal的指令
但只是我们写的时候只写了这个van
但是呢它自动把我翻译成matter的
原生态指令而已
所以这也是我们的一个考虑
那么就是说我们上节课的那课程作业的话
给大家讲的就是我们尽可能的给大家延期到
就是这个月的中下旬
如果有必要的话
我们再去研究
因为这也是同学们特别关心的一个问题
好的我们的q and a part花了我们的6分钟
那我们先给大家讲到这为止
因为今天我稍微有点delay
所以的话呢我这边稍微赶一点时间
说话语速有点高
同学们原谅一下好
今天进入到我们的课程的正题了
就继续讲工具对吧
其实工具真的是博大精深
那今天的话呢
这节课其实是我们比较难以准备的一节课
为什么呢
上一节课讲的全是工具链的一些基本的
fundamental的原理
那这节课呢实际上我们要讲一些高级的
讲一些应用的东西
但是我们在讲的时候
我一直在思考的一个问题
就是说如何把这一节课不要变成一个
就是像我们在比如说在各大视频网上
随便能找到大量的这个叫游戏引擎的使用的
这种这种这个教你怎么使用游戏引擎对吧
给你介绍每个工具的详细的功能
怎么去用它
怎么去组合
怎么组合你的变化
因为那这个呢更像是一个游戏引擎教学视频
但今天呢我们讲的还是一个
就是如何去编写或者架构自己的一个游戏引擎
所以今天其实你看到我我们的课程准备中啊
我个人觉得是我们最精分的一节课程
但是呢我们在尽我们的所所能
就是说尽可能的讲一些就是fundamental的
就是底层的东西
然后呢上面的一些application我们会点一下
因为你没有
确实是如果我们不知道application的话
大家不理解底层为什么这么写
但是呢如果我们只专注于上面的application的话呢
哎我们又会忽视掉下面
其实它有一层底层的架构解决方案
所以这是我们这节课尝试想找到的
这样的一个平衡点
好那话不多说
给大家介绍一下我们这节课的主要内容
那么这节课的话呢
我们大概分成这么几个part
第一个呢
我们还是非常快速的
让同学们对这个游戏的真正的production
有一个感觉对吧
那么第二个的话呢
就是说我们呢接下来会围绕着一个重点呢
也是我们一直搭同学们最熟悉的叫地图编辑器
基本上所有摸过游戏引擎的同学
都知道这个东西对吧
那我们今天要简单讲一下诶
如果我们要架构一个地图地图编辑器
我们怎么去架构
那第三个的话呢
我们其实在上一节课给大家讲的就是
plugin对吧
插件机制是工具体系最核心的一个机制
那今天的话呢我会稍微展开一点点
跟同学们讨论一下
就是说一个plugin architecture该怎么做
就是在游戏引擎里面
Plugin accture
到底他这个有哪些坑
怎么去
就是可能会在哪上踩雷对吧
那么后面的话呢会跟他讲两个重点呢
非常有意思的系统
第一个就是说一个线性的一个叙事性系统
在工具体怎么表达
但我这里面会用sequencer举个例子
但是同学们一定要意识到
就是在游戏中啊
线性系统绝不止一个SEQUER
其实很多系统它都是线性的
就是说你希望点一个play开始
然后呢他依次会发生所有你想发生的事情
那么第四这啊倒数第二排的话
也是同学们这个一直很期待的
就是很多同学问我们说
诶
能不能给我们讲一下
小引擎里面的这个反射系统是怎么做的对吧
那么其实的话呢在这节课里面呢
我们会稍微花几页笔墨跟同学们详细的讲一下
我们都反射到底是怎么东西
因为反射我们认为四工具链里面
做game play的一个非常重要的一个基础
那最后的话呢会给大家点一下
一个比较有意思的东西
高级的东西就是协作式编辑
因为我们认为就是说协作式的编辑工具的话呢
会将是下一代游戏引擎发展的一个重点方向
对吧
因为我们现在要处理的游戏世界越来越丰富
越来越复杂了
所以呢这就是我们今天的主要内容
首先的话呢大家一起来看一下
就是说游戏的production到底是什么一个状态
那这是一段小小的视频
这个就是那个育碧的这个各各他自己的
in house的这个引擎
你可以看到
就是说
其实在这样的一个真实的游戏studio里面的话
大家会在艺术家会用各种各样的工具
有人在建这个场景的layout
有人在设计的game play
然后当我们点了一个一键的play之后
哎
在这里面游戏用户会产生各种各样复杂的行为
但这里面有大量的比如说用词
就我们叫做那个
就是那个那个那个叫PGC对吧
程序化方法自动生成的东西
也有大量的for designer的这样的一个
FIRMWORK和框架性的东西
那么在这里面的话呢
artist就是说甚至可以变换
自动化的生成一个整个城市
那么这里面当然还有很多的
比如说我们叫做concept artist
他设置这个角色和场景的外观对吧
然后呢我们要生成大量的那个那个model alex
它生成3D的模型
这些东西这些所有东西全部连接在一起
形成了我们一个真正的一个商业级游戏的production
那最后交个交付到大家手上的东西
是非常的非常有意思的
你可以看到一个非常有趣的游戏
但这个游戏这里面的话
就说所有的东西它都是有语义的
所有的东西都尽可能让玩家能够可交互
可playable的
Ok anyway
那我们继续讲一下
就是说其实呢整个工具链
它还有一个很大的一个挑战
就是说真正在实战的游戏中的话
我们知道就是游戏有很多类型
在这里教给大家一个有意思的词儿
叫JA
我们经常讲游戏类型对吧
英文怎么说叫JA这个词呢
其实来自于法语
就表示各种各样不同类型的游戏
比如说我们讲RBGFPS对吧
这个这个MOBA都都叫JA
那其实对于不同java的游戏的话呢
实际上他所要做的这种编辑操作
它的这种game play的设置
甚至关卡的layout都会完全关
关卡的组织规范都会完全不一样
那么这个其实也是我们工具体系
一个非常复杂的一个东西
那么工具体系的话
但这样的一个结构和体系的话呢
实际上我们要和很多的工具在一起了
这张图的话大家有点熟悉对吧
这是我们在这个就是games
在第一节课也给大家展示了这样的一张图
包括这也是我推荐的那本教材
叫game engine architecture
里面很经典的一张图
但这里面的话我要跟大家讲一个fax
就是说实际上这张图是错的
什么意思呢
就是说这张图根本就没有把游戏的工具层画全
这里面缺了很多很多的工具
包括有些工具的关系
可能现代游戏引擎已经发生了一些变化
但是没有关系
我只想让大家看这个图
就明白一个道理
就是说
其实在真正做这个工具链
体系设计的时候的话呢
我们实际上是要解决
就像我一上来讲
就是解决来自于完全不同的思维方式
就是艺术家设计师
程序员在一起能够协同协作的问题
而且在整个过程中的话呢
我们都要保证那个很高大上的原则是什么
WYSIWYG对吧
这个这个名字比YYDS听上去酷多了
就是所见即所得
而且这个呢实际上是现代游戏生产中
一个非常重要的一个指标
为什么
因为我们在跟大量的艺术家
设计师在一起工作的时
他们会发现
如果我们没有办法再工具这一层
保证大家的所见所得的话
它会极大地影响到游戏产品的不仅是效率
就是效率肯定是周期会变长
对不对
还要影响那个它的质量
为什么呢
因为比如举个例子吧
比如说level artist
如果a level designer就是有那个关卡设计师
如果他不能真的快速的看到他调整完的关卡
长什么样子
而且自己真的能身临其境的在中间走
其实他很多时候的判断
比如说这个地方我希望天上一个落石
那个地方我希望有一个小怪蹦出来
那个体验实际上是全错的
他完全不能模拟用户真实的体验
如果你不能带入到用户真实的体验中的话
那你给出来的设计一定是不好的
那这就对工具产生了一个非常大的一个挑战
为什么呢
因为其实大家如果我待会会讲的
就是如果在做工具的时候
你有大量的就是额外的信息
额外的操作
才能够允许艺术家或者设计师
真的对它进行编辑和调整对吧
甚至我还要解决同步版本控制的问题
但是你又要求这一切的东西
就是看起来跟真实的游戏一模一样
这个其实啊
这两个东西有的时候是忠孝不可两全的
但是呢就是我们在上一节课也讲到了
就是说我们最后大家总结出来
就是说把游戏
直接把工具直接包在游戏引擎外面
是一个现在大家公认的比较好的企划
但这个也会给游戏引擎带来一些挑战
我后面会很详细的讲到这一点好
那么其实呢我们先从一个工具开始讲起来对吧
因为我们这个游戏引擎课
并不需要讲所有的游戏工具链上的工具
因为那个工具量
那个数量可能是几十个为单位的
那我们就讲一个word editor
就是word是地图编辑器呢
实际上很多人在讲word extra是一个哎
我就是拖拉拽的一个工具
对不对
各种东西拖拉拽
但是其实从我们专业的游戏
引擎架构的思想来讲的话
我们认为他是个hub
什么意思呢
就是说它实际上是一个平台
我们把各种各样的我们在游戏的世界里面
需要构建的逻辑玩法
场景内容在中间进行
能够插进去的这样的一个平台
所以我们上节课讲到plugin的机制
所以这一点的话呢
是当我们自己去架构自己的word的时候
首先把这句话记在脑子里面
你千万不要一上来就写编辑器
写写这种就是这个这个类似3D max的拖拽
选的这种逻辑
这种东西重不重要
非常的重要
但是呢你会让你很快速的这种方法
会让你快速的得到一个诶
看上去很酷的这样的一个编辑器
而且你甚至产生一个错觉
说诶我是不是可以跟unreal pk一下了对吧
我以前就经常看到我们那个很多论坛上
就会说啊
我这个什么什么东西超过了虚化
那其实从就是专业的游戏体研发来讲的话
我觉得我们还是要非常尊重那些优秀的
商业级的引擎
因为确实他们去是他们的核心
不在于一个一个的feature
而在于整个体系
我是按什么一种逻辑把它架构起来的
所以这是我认为
就当我们去做世界编辑器的时候
最先在脑中建立了这样的一个概念好
那我们打开我们还是以虚幻为例吧
你看一个虚幻的源码
打开来
你会发现它的上面买的时东西特别多
比如说你可以看到VIEWPORT对吧
你看到上面很多的按钮图吧
你可以看到layout啊
这个什么layers levels啊
什么outlier details
对不对
还有counter brother1大堆东西
那当然你看着很复杂
而且这只是面板展示的方式之一啊
如果你打开一个商业级引擎的这个what editor的话
它的面板可以切换到很多很多的view
对不对
比如说我们看那个我们的一个
真实的游戏团队的话
你会发现比如说同样是一个引擎打开来
如果是做animation的
如果是做那个场景编辑的对吧
如果是做玩法编辑的
它的面板就完全不一样的
这这就是解释了就是为什么就像我讲这个world editor
它是个hub
就是说实际上它集成了很多功能
但是呢对于不同的用户
它又呈现出了不同的view
那么在这样的一个庞大的这样的一个体系中
最重要的几个体系是什么呢
我这边就给我个人的理解给大家总结一下
抛砖引玉一下
第一个呢我认为最重要的是什么呢
诶editor里面的那个VIEWPORT对吧
这个VIEWPORT是什么呢
就是最重要的
我们的用户和你想构建的游戏事件交互的窗口
那么这个东西他是怎么做的呢
其实在上一节课我们已经点赞了
我这边再明确讲一下
就是它其实下面跑的就是一个游戏引擎
就是一个游戏
但是呢这个游戏的版本呢
我上面打了个flag叫editor mode
因为在这个editor mode下呢
你就能做很多真实的游戏不能做的事情啊
比如说我的我的相机可以自由的飞来飞去对吧
我可以无视所有的碰撞
我可以把很多东西变成透明的
然后呢我可以显示很多debug draw
While wifi mode
对不对
那么这里面会提供很多的
我们叫做gadget
就是说诶那个小坐标系给你显示一下呀
选点选选选那个点
取那个点曲啊
选中啊
还有一些东西
grouping啊
line啊
这些这些东西这些基础的操作的话呢
最基础的一些东西
是需要在引擎里用native code给你说的
因为这样效率也非常高
但是呢上面一些更复杂的逻辑
当然我们可以用编辑器自己来处理
那这里面有一个很有意思的细节
就是说这就意味着我们的引擎的代码
会有一些代码是叫editor only的代码
那么这个东西的话呢
它的版本就是不一样的
那么这里面我就特别给大家注意一件事
当我们自己架构自己的引擎的时候
这也是初级的
这个这个新入行的同学特别容易犯的一个错误
是什么呢
就是说如果我们不小心把这些编辑器的代码
编译到我们上线发布的游戏里面去的话
那么这极有可能会成为别人写外挂的一个
很重要的这个入口对吧
就是诶我我让整个世界都透明了
我我让这个什么什么东西选取直接就有了对吧
或者我可以直接飞来飞去了
当然了也有
但是其实外挂并不是这么写的
但是如果我们不小心把这个H的代码的话
放出去的话
只要人家找到那些函数名和指针的话
它其实用起来特别的方便
所以的话呢
就是这个是我们在所有的引擎架构的时候
我们都会问
因为特别是在一个大型的游戏团队啊
啊游戏引擎团的人数是非常多的
工程师的话会到上百人左右
那就特别容易出现一些没有经验的
我们的开发的同学会诶
应我们的策划和设计师要求
做了一个工具和功能
大家都觉得很好用
然后呢策划和设计那个美术都很满意
但是的话呢就是他忘了把这段代码
把它包在那个就是editor onion那个红下面
结果这段代码就被编译出去了
然后有的时候会产生这样的一个问题
所以这件事情的话呢
就是说一定要区分区分了
所以VIEWPORT这件事情的话
大家记住记牢了
就是说它实际上就是跑的是一个完整的游戏
这件事情非常的重要
因为它是最基本的一个保证知识
那个我们讲的所见即所得
因为特别是对于artist很敏感的
比如像才智对吧
我做了一个无效
我的光从这边打过来
我希望他反射几下
把一个角色给照亮
包括我做一个过场动画
我希望那个角色正好走进阴影
这些是很细腻的一个光和反射
它必须要通过这样的一个架构才能实现得了
所以Viper是你做WORDOR最重要的一个
一个和他是最好不要做plugin的
它本身也没有必要做plugin
但这里面要讲一个有意思的细节是什么呢
就是说呃实际上在一个真正的这个world editor
商业级的word editor里面的话呢
VIEWPORT有的时候不止一个的
就比如说你在做过场动画的时候
哎你编辑的是一个VIEWPORT的
但是你还希望有个VIEWPORT去看它
你甚至会做好几个VIP的
所以呢当我们去做一个编辑系统架构的时候呢
我们经常要让VIP的支持多个view
其实这里面的话
其实对你的引擎架构也提出了一个要求
为什么呢
因为你不能把数据同时拷贝好几分
对不对
那你编辑了一个数据的时候
你还要像那个好几分的引擎
你考同步数据吗
那不相当于在本地写了一个小型的网络
同步了嘛
对不对
所以的话呢
当我们再去写这样editor viewport的时候的话呢
我们实际上是要对引擎那边要做个改造
就是让它能兼容多个view
当然有的时候在我们某些游戏中的话
我们也也需要实现这种画中画
所以也作为我们的一个需求
那么第二个呢很重要的一个窗口是什么呢
就是说在我们的整个这个游戏世界里面啊
其实我们有很多很多的东西
比如说我们天空都有语音
有角色在编辑器里面的话呢
就是我们其实要编辑的元素特别的多对吧
我们有天上的语音
地上的这个这个NPC树上的那个那个一花
一木一草
那么这里面有一个很重要的原则
就是其实我们在第一节课
第二节课就特别是第二节课讲的特别清楚
就是说所有的东西都是物体
都是那个object
那么这里面object呢在编辑器里面的话呢
我们也会讲说所有的object都是editable的
就是说都是可被编辑的
但是当然了
不同的引擎说法不一样
比如说虚幻引擎里面我们会叫他actor对吧
那个unity里面我们会叫他object
比如像我们我自己做的引擎的话
我会叫他object
对不对
但这不重要
重要的就是说其实啊我们会发现
不论你是什么
在这个世界里的对象
你都是有一些可以编辑的东西
比如说我要至少能选中你吧对吧
我至少能改变你的位置吧
我至少能旋转你吧
对不对
然后呢我点中你的时候
我想编辑你的一些属性吧
所以这个呢也是当我们去做word editor的时候
我们最核心的要思考的第一件事情
就是说在架构上
就是说我要把这个世界你的一切的东西
比如说大地天空语音
你是天上的飞鸟
每一个人都把它抽象成一个common
这样的一个editable object
对吧
这这跟enery object还有一点点不太一样
就是它相当于那个object再往上再走一步
那么其实呢这里面就产生第二个问题了
这也是我在讲的
就是大家如果在下个word editicia
你会遇到的问题
就是说我们实际上一个真实的实战的一个
游戏产品来讲的话
一个场景里面对象数有多少呢
基本上至少是几千个甚至是上万个甚至更多
大家有没有想象过
就是如果我给你一个文件目录里面
给你上万个文件
你怎么去管理它
其实你很多时候不会管你
你看到的文件是123456789十对吧
好
没问题
你都记住了
但第二天你回来再打开这个编辑器的时候
问D973号文件
它到底是什么东西
你看他根本不知道
当然你说哎呦
我可以通过文件名
但是当你的对象数足够足够多的时候
实际上这个东西你已经完全失控了
注意啊
这里面你看到的还不是对象文件
它是不会重复的
对不对
那么但是的话呢
我们在这个世界里面
看到大量的是对象的instance
它的一个一个instance
那么好
就是那这个数量就会非常大
所以你会发现在一个商业级的游戏引擎里面
当我们设计它的word ash的时候
我要对这么多的对象object
我要设计出很多种不同的view
比如说最经典的是树状的view
就是我把这些物体诶
我给它进行归类对吧
我一个个目录去存储它
那么唉我有的时候会把它分成不同的layer
就是说啊这个是地上的植被
这个是城市左边的这个建筑群
那边的话是所有的地上的这个这个这个石头
这样的话我用大的这个layer去去把它进行
归类的话
我也可以把它进行group
但其实这样的话还不够
有的时候我们还需要什么
还有search去寻找它
所以说其实你会发现一个商业级的引擎的话呢
它对于这样的一个lisper objects的话呢
它会提供了很多种view
而对于artist来讲的话
我们会根据artist的习惯
比如说有的人我就是喜欢做这个啊
我是做environment
我只是专门做天空大气系统的ALICE的那好
我会对其他的view我都不重要
我会让你们都锁住
不让你去边它
或者说我把它引掉
让我专注的去调整上面的这个天空
云和雨这种感觉的效果的东西
然后我再把你接回来
我再看你的效果
所以说当我们去设计这样的一个word editor的时候
我们的object系统一定要把就是记得上节课讲过的
他我们的模型什么MVVM模型
对不对
数据model一定要动起来
它的view其实可以提供很多种不同的view
完全可以根据艺术家的情况
甚至在未来可以允许不同的
这个就是designer或者artist
他用不同的view去管理它的对象
那么其实呢
这个时候
当我们有了这样的一个view的列表的时候
大家想到最正常的情况是什么
就是我们最直观的编辑是什么
诶不是什么特殊的编辑器
就是在这个地图编辑里面
我选中一个东西
我就想直接编辑它的属性
比如说我选择MPC
我想设置它的血量
对不对
那这个时候呢
我们在上一节课讲的schema系统就很重要了
就是说我点中它
我通过schema可以反射出来
他身上到底挂了有多少的属性数据
那么我们的编辑器
可以自动的根据你的属性的类型
生成它所需要的这个编辑界面
所以说像这样的一个界面的话
几乎是所有的引擎的这个word editor总有一个小panel
比如像ARIAL里面这个panel叫什么
叫detail对吧
像有的隐形叫properties
对不对
这都可以
但是的话呢这就让你去可以编辑这个东西
这个呢也是当我们去构建word editor的时候
这个window是一定要需要在的好
那么这最后呢
这也是就是说我们在做引擎的时候
非常重要的一个东西
这个是我希望大家在写引擎的时候
一定要注意的一个东西
就是counter brother
诶
我这里面我要小小的这个这个自夸一下
我们的PILA对吧
我pick a真的是一个小到不能再小的一个引擎
就几万行代码
但是的话呢当时架构的时候这么小的引擎
我们的团队还是架构了counter brother
当时我看到这个架构的时候
我还真的非常的惊喜
为什么呢
因为其实真实的一个游戏引擎是做什么的
可是给大家做游戏开发的
对不对好
那么游戏开发的实际情况是什么呢
就是你想啊
我们一个游戏产品有几十个甚至上百个artist
然后呢我们会生产什么呢
我们会生产几十几几十件甚至几啊几几10万件
是几万到几10万件的不同的资产
这里的资产有什么
有动画对吧
有三维的模型
还有什么呢
声音效果
还有我们想要的一些漂亮的UI贴图
动图这些东西
这些东西啊
它实际上是非常丰富和复杂的
那我们最直观的想这东西怎么管理
其实在我刚刚进入游戏引擎这个行业的时候
我们怎么做呢
我们其实那时候没有counter browser
我们就唉有一个technic artist
他非常的厉害
他也很有经验
它会根据你的产品把所有的资产设定好
比如说我那时做halo好
halo3对吧
所有的资产比如说objects
对不对
你的这个这个foolish就植被对吧
这个什么objects
你去看你们还有什么vehicle载具
什么weapon枪对吧
分得很清楚
然后呢这里面再点进去
你再分哪些是哪个目录
是贴图的
哪个目录是模型的
哪个目录是原始数据的哇
我的天呐
就是你钻下去
发现是一个非常深的一个树状结构
然后呢好我们的artist
当然我们的团队很很遵守规则
大家都把这个数据都放进去了
形成了一个很漂亮的一个ree view
但这个问题就来了
当我做完了halo3之后
我要做halo4怎么办
对吧
黑龙寺不是所有资产都全部重新来过一遍
对不对
我很多资产还要从黑龙三去继承的
那好这你们的资产怎么去重用呢
怎么去共同管理呢
对不对
比如说我我一个艺术家在做黑楼四的时候
我想用黑龙三你们的某一把枪
哎呀
那我还得到那个目录里面去找
那好了
那这个资产到底应该放到黑龙三的目录
还黑罗斯的目录
你讲不清楚了
对不对
而且这个目录结构呢一旦设置好
很多时候他是3年到4年前有一个人设置好的
他很多时候是不能预判整个游戏发展到后来的
这种复杂的变化对吧
我们后面会产生很多很多不同的需求
所以差不多在这个就是说小10年前吧
就是大家提出了这个content browser这个想法
实际上在我看来
在这里面的话
我们当然还会支持这种基于文件夹
文件夹的这样一个结构的东西
但是它更多的只是个view
而我们怎么去看待这所有的资产呢
我们会认为它就像放到一个巨大的那个
ocean的里面
一个池子里面
然后呢这些资产扔进去
你只需要知道它是你要什么东西
你要它叫什么名字
然后你就能检索到它
它你就能够去挂了它
然后呢你可以根据你不同的项目
形成这个资产的一个view对吧
这个view你也可以用树状去管理
但是没关系
这资产放在那儿
你不用管
甚至这个资产都不需要放到你的本地
它可以放到一个数据库里面
其实那个在最早我刚开始我们在加引擎的时候
最早学引擎的时候
现在还在美国的时候
我们就很有很有兴趣的研究一个概念
就是说诶我们要不要在本地都不要存这些资产
因为这数据都特别特别大对吧
我们把它放在一个studio的
一个中央的这个数据仓库里面
然后呢每个人你需要用到什么资产的时候
你只是把它用到你的内存里面
因为你本质上是要跑个游戏嘛
这样的话就避免就避省去了这些几个T的资产
在各上百台机器中来回考的这个时间
而且的话还有很多的预计算可以提前做掉
但这个我今天就不展开了
但是这个content browser的话
实际上就是这件事情的一个
最重要的一个解决方案
也就是说我们真的把这个是asset
从一个静态的文件目录变成了一个资源的海洋
所以说ocean这个词的话
其实在现在很多现代游戏引擎的企业里面啊
游戏公司的企业里面都已经用到了
所以说的话呢
今天如果我们假设一个面向未来的游戏情的话
那counter browser是大家必须要考虑的东西
那么其实讲完这些东西的话
大家基本上你再去分析啊
就是这个word editor上的各种小元件的话
你基本上也就清楚
What
你仔细看它
他无非也就解决三个问题
第一个layout的问题对吧
我各种东西的就是摆放啊
一些东西的碰撞啊检测
还有呢就是以地形为基础的
比如说上面的植被
上面的这个这个decorator
就是各种各样的小的杂物对吧
还有什么呢
还有我们要的environment
比如天空啊
天光啊
光源啊这些所有的东西
那么其实的话呢
这些东西呢就是一个最基本的WORDASH
我们用的各种unit或者叫各各个系统
那么在这里面的话
大家很关心啊
那我这个what一下去写
他说最关键的东西是什么呢
啊第一步要写的东西是什么呢
那么其实如果架构没有问题的话
那第一个要写的诶还真的是鼠标的选取
因为鼠标的选曲啊其实是一切的基础
实际上我们在用很多编辑器
你觉得顺手不顺手
实际上跟鼠标选曲写的好坏有很大的关系
很多时候鼠标的选取甚至是模糊一点
让你就是让艺术家用起来更自然
那么好
这里面有两种比较简单的做法了
一种比如说我用recasting
就是说既然我这个世界里所有的物体
我都有包围盒对吧
那我就recasting呗
我就cos一下
我就hit到他了
那这个的话呢实际上他用的其实是物理引擎
或者说我对这个世界的物理表示
他有的时候呢你说他要做的粗做一下是很快的
但是呢如果我要做得很精准
因为你们知道一个物体的形状是七扭八拐的
对吧
我一个角色站在那儿
你在远处看着小小的就就那一小块儿
但是呢他可能有几万个三角形面片
然后我我用它的胶囊去做做选取的话
可能你想选的是他身后的那棵树
但是你发现你错误的选择前面的人
所以这个时候呢有的人就有的引擎的做法
就是说哎我直接加一个额外的选取帧
就是说我把每个object id打在这个frame buffer上
然后呢你就去取到那个像素
取到那个问题就可以了
这个方法其实就是哎这就是刚才我讲的
就是你如果引擎跑的是editor mode的话
你可能就要加一个这个extra的pass
去渲染这样的一个带有object id的这样一个texture
那么这个肯定会费一点
但没关系嘛
一般来讲我们做做编辑时候
用的电脑会比玩家的电脑会更好
就是说大家如果你做过主机开发
就知道
比如说像那个PLAYSTATION和XBOX的话
它都有一个叫开发者dev mode
就是开发者版本它额外的跟以前内存
但是的话呢我们讲我们的开发者
PC的话也是一样的
我们会额外的加很多内存
都配最好的显卡
所以我们的程序员经常会犯的
一个一个踩了一个坑
就是说诶在我的本机跑起来完全没有问题啊
为什么在用户那边电脑卡呀
很多手是因为我为了能做开发
做编辑用的这种电脑的话
配置都是比较高的
artist有时候也会这样
但没关系
这都是细节
所以其实呢首先鼠标能选中一个物体
这件事就得认真写一写
但这里面有个细节
就是说
我们假设这个场景里面有很多透明性的物体
打个比方
比如说很多particle对吧
你想选中国particle怎么办
你想选中一块玻璃怎么办
如果按照我们之前讲的说透明物的话
它是不写入DEBUFFER的
对不对
他会被直接过滤掉
所以这个时候的话呢
你们要需要写一些特殊的代码和逻辑去表达它
举个例子
比如像particle很多引起你的做法怎么办呢
哎我在party发生器那个地方
我作为一个虚拟体对吧
其实你选中的不是那个particle
你选的可能是下面那个根的那个虚拟
你把它选中就给拖来拖去
拖来拖去了
那么对于其他的一些更复杂的选取的话呢
一般来讲我们都会有一些特殊的code来解决它
所以真的大家再做一个
就是游戏引擎的选取的话
你会发现你要考虑的情况下特别的特别的多好
那其实呢当我们可以选取一个物体的时候
大家会发现
就是在游戏引擎里面有大量的物体的
我们叫做transform操作
什么意思呢
就是把它平移旋转
还有什么呢
放松对吧
这个在我们在一开始讲那个object的时候
我在讲物理讲述的都讲了大量的这个这个东西
但是其实在做word ash editor的时候
这些地方反而是特别容易出问题的
为什么呢
因为这个地方的话就是有大量的
比如说3D max maya
包括像其他的游戏引擎
给我们的artist的
形成了非常多的一些优良的操作习惯
这些习惯都是经过很多项目常年总结下来
你会发现就是一个简单的旋转
那当你按哪个热键会出现旋转的空间
旋转的空间
当你的鼠标往上移动的时候
移动到那个那个get的百分之多少的时候
诶
它的X轴的旋转还是Y轴的旋转
Z轴的旋转会被高亮对吧
都会这个有很多讲究
如果你做的不好
别人用起来就非常不认识
我给你讲
大家讲个小例子
就比如说在我们在做旋转的时候
你会发现我只要鼠标一动就旋转好了
对不对
诶但是我们的设计师需要一个模式
是说我希望整度数旋转
比如每隔五度旋转一下
这样方便我什么呢
诶很快的对齐
比如说90度
45度
这个180度是吧
135度这几个常用的度数或者是30度
60度
所以这些东西的话呢
就是如果真的想写得好的话
很多时候你会写好几个月
而且很细心的打磨
所以这个地方为什么跟大家去讲呢
这也是说其实在我们在真的做一个word editor这样的
或者说一个工具链的时候
它其实大的框架很容易讲得清楚
但是的话当我们真正去写它的时候
你会发现你要想写得好
还是有很高的这个门槛的
这也是就是说商业级引擎
让大家觉得很敬畏的地方好
那么接下来我们有了这样的两个工具
我们就可以摆摆layout了
对不对
那接下来我们就说哎
我们地形和地形相关的一些吧
地形的话在前面GRX的那个那个那趴的话
大家都知道地形我知道很简单
不就是一个高度图嘛
对不对
高度图无非就是个high field
再加上一个texture吗
对的确实就是这么简单
然后呢你再加上这高度图到底怎么生成的呢
那我在前面讲了那个PCC对吧
用程序化自动生成
但实际上呢在现在游戏中
很多时候我们可能还要加很多的其他小工具
那另外一个这上面不止不止是一个山川河流
对不对
我们有大量的这种植被啊
大量的地形的变化呀
这些东西是怎么生成的
那在我们去构建一个word editor的时候
我们最核心要提供的模块是什么
这里面呢我只给大家点几个
比较常重要的一个模块
那大家首先猜到了就是哎对high brush
就是说我能够对高度进行这种刷
那这个大家想象一下1heat press是不是非常简单
对不对
定义好了吗
一个追杀嘛
或者一个平台删
我就给你拉起来嘛
但实际上当大家对于一个有限密度的这个high field
这个网格进行做笔刷操作的时候
你会发现对这个信号进行合理化的
smooth是最重要的
也就是说你会发现艺术家
你你你觉得你提供了所有的药的形状的功能
但艺术家说我总是拉不出我想要那个山的形状
因为其实你们的差距并不是你的笔刷种类
而是什么呢
是你拉出来之后
其实艺术家希望他的过度尽可能的自然
那这个自然是怎么定义的
所以这个smooth就是有很多的细节和讲究
包括大家想象一下我们的high field
那个船狗是斜着的
一个个过去的对吧
实际上它它你可以理理解成这个布
它本身是沿着某一个轴向被切割过的
当你去拉高度的时候
拉的不好
你会发现它有个很明显的
沿着你那个选择45度切向的
那个那个过渡角
你就能感觉到那个height那边的
是有点ZZ的那种感觉
所以其实的话呢
如何去有效的
就是让这个刷出来的山看上去更smooth
更自然的话实际上是个high的笔
刷一个很重要的东西
另外一个的话呢
也是我们在实践中发现的一个点
就是说其实艺术家很多时候希望的是什么呢
他也需要一种可扩展的能力
虽然我们作为技术人员
会给大家提供很多的笔刷
但是当我们真的写一个游戏引擎的时候
我会强烈建议大家提供艺术家
可以自己导入一个高度图
自己定义一个笔刷的能力
其实这个东西会让他们乐此不疲
当然了
就是大家如果研究一下胡迪尼的话
你会发现就是说这方面他做的更加的强大
这也是就是说当我们去做工具的时候
首先就是不要专注的是哎我的算法多么的厉害
而是说我的这个东西可它的扩展性有多强
知识速工具
首先脑子中要想了一个问题
那么另外一种笔刷呢就是非常非常常见
就是叫instance brush
就是说刷各种各样的实体
比如说刷那个小的那个那个detail对吧
刷decorator就是地面上的那个小小草
当然也包括刷这个tree
那么这个东西其实是一个非常直觉的东西
就是当我要大面积的刷草种树的时候
我就会用这个方法去做
但这里面会有个很有意思的点是什么呢
就是说啊首先他这个方法非常的简单
非常的好对吧
比如像刷数
我一下能刷很多很多输出来
那么每一棵树都是独立的存储
这样的话其实我真的能实现
就是说当我去看它的时候
它在这个位置
我游戏跑起来它一定在这个位置
这个数现在是一个偏黄色的树
游戏跑起来它一定也是偏黄色的树
因为这些所有的属性全部定就是静态的
放在那儿
那这个时候如果我对这一棵树不满意对吧
我或者说说想挖一条小道出来
那我可以上手一个一个去改也没有问题
所以这是instant base的一个非常好的一个方一个点
但是它的缺点是什么呢
就是啊如果大家以一个实战型的游戏来看的话
比如说你方圆几十平方公里
你会发现光你把这些树的位置去存一存
它的内存占用就已经非常大了
然后的话呢它有很多的预处理
其实非常的麻烦
但是呢这个东西的话呢
后面可能要用一些PGC的方法去解决它
那这里面就不展开
但这个呢不妨碍就是说instant笔刷是游戏的引擎
一个很关键的一个笔刷好
那么另外一个呢我就不展开了
就是说实际上这个听上去很像有心情了
因为具体的算法我在图形学科已经讲过了
就说哎你需要对光大量的光源的摆放
其实现代游戏引擎啊
随着我们的GPU能力越来越强
我有时候觉得我们越来越像那个电影行业
就是你知道
就是当我们在电影里面拍摄一个场景的时候
实际上我们的艺术家会布置很多辅助性光源
会把那个角色刻画的特别好
或者会把那个就是说呃
某一个场景的气氛渲染的特别好
其实现在游戏研发的时候
很多时候气氛都是靠这种光啊
滤镜啊
包括这个天空的云啊
天光啊打出来的
那这些environment的话呢
实际上都是啊有各种各样的插件来协作去完成
那么我们今天再去做这个word editor的时候
一定要给这些插件留下空间
其实呢这里面就是what edita
我认为就是大家在在思考的时候特别容易忽略
但是有很重要的一点
就是说实际上我刚才讲的这一个个的插件
你说他坐下来难不难
其实不难
因为你知道了前面所有的这个算法的
对不对
真正难的是什么呢
哎这些东西在于彼此是有一些规则的
举个例子
比如说我们在这个世界里要修一条路
诶
这个路就有很多规则了
比如说路上不能长树
对不对
是不能树长了路中江
而且呢我的那些杂草也不应该长在路的两边
对吧
然后呢这个路我画出来
我认为是一个方向
对不对
但是如果我的train有高低起伏的话
我这个路不能够什么逢山开山
逢水架桥对吧
他应该是沿着这个terrain的起伏有一个起伏
但是呢他又要修改tern
为什么
因为大家知道路得平嘛对吧
你头上有的时候是斜的
你你们没有很少看到那个路修的是倾斜十度
15度对吧
那所以路实际上呢
它既要符合那个terrain的高低
他又要在turn上进行一个切割的这个操作
然后呢还有什么呢
就是说诶就是说我们的这个就是说啊
我们的一些石头或者是一些其他的东西的话呢
就是它应该碎石子
它应该沿着路的两边有一个路基的这样的东西
所以说其实啊一个最简单的一个roll的系统
大家理解一下
我们在上节课讲rose系统很简单对吧
你就拉个LIN就完事了
但实际上你真的在一个word里面
做一个rose系统的话是很麻烦的
大家说诶那我可不可以不处理对吧
我很简单
我大不了
首先把路弄好之后
我开始artist上手
该砍树的砍树
该把decade清理掉
清理掉
对不对
然后turn我上手去修
同学们想象一下这个工作量是不是非常大
OK没关系
我我我我忍受得了
这工作量很大
但第二个问题就来了
这个问题其实也是更严重的一个问题
就是说今天我作为一个lol artist
我认为这个路这样开是有道理的对吧
但是我的designer
我的设计师说你录这样修的时候
我的那个比如说这个这个这个战斗
这个combat就没法打了
就敌人直接就冲过来了对吧
我我得在这边做个拐角
这样的话呢我可以在这边设埋伏对吧
这样敌人那个大炮不能直接射到我
这样的话我的游戏才有的玩儿好了
设计师那个那个那个LEVELIST被要求重新改
这个这个这个录的这个方向的时候
大家知道吗
这个时候就整个就完蛋了
因为你前面做的所有的工作全部得重做一遍
所以其实我们必须要用一种procedure的方法
就是程序的方法自动解决这个问题
而这个时候怎么办
哎唯一呢就我们就是一套rule system
就是我们通过一套复杂的这种GRAF
把这些入都表达出来
然后呢我们把原始的数据分层分的很清楚
比如说这是你的画好的tree的分布对吧
这是你的这个road的分布
这是你上面的这些object的分布
因为我们不希望这个TRA
涨到这个这个房子里面
对不对
我们希望房子周边多少米之内不能长树好
包括你的河流水在哪里
我也标标注出来
然后呢
这些所有的地形元素我全部都有
之后我交给计算机
用我的规则体系生成一套我们想要的
这样的一个合理的数的分布
这个时候这个效果才是对的
这件事情讲讲很简单
其实你真的让它简单生成一下很简单
但这里面我个人认为
一直以来我一直在思考或者想解决的一个问题
叫deterministic
什么意思
就是说当我改了一个局域的时候
如果我这个数的分布
因为树的分布
大家希望是随机的嘛对吧
但是呢我希望其他已经生成好了
我已经满意的地方
那些树不要再全部重新生成一遍
因为有的时候我对你上次生的结果是很满意的
我只想改个局部
所以说如何能保证这种generate data
它具有一种叫做locality
就是说局部性其实是一个实战化的
这个就是word editor很重要的一个一个一个属性
那在这里给大家
因为这门课的话呢
我们只是给大家打个基础
让大家意识到
就是说其实环境编辑最重要的就是这套rule system
那给大家看这个别人做完了一个结果
我觉得这个结果还是蛮impressive的
其实但这个呢
实际上已经不算是什么先进的技术了
基本上商业性引擎都要提供这样的功能
大家可以看到他一上来再刷这些植被的时候
他会很快的检测到
就是有路有石头的地方
它就会那个让开
包括像这么大件的树
它也是这样
而且呢
这个时候他如果对这个路进行改造的时候
所有的植被都会相应的发生变化
其实这个技术差不多在十几年前的哈
大家就开始在研究
到今天的话呢
其实特别是基于这个DEPLANAI的
这些技术的成熟啊
实际上这件事情已经是非常非常的
这个will study problem
就是大家都已经解决的相当好的一个问题了
但是这里面真正难的问题是什么呢
就是说如何去定义一套形式化的语言
让我们的设计师能够定义这套规则
包括这套规则很简单很易懂
很好维护
这其实是一个很很有意思的
而且这里面再讲个游戏的细节啊
就是说真正在啊我记得罗没记错
应该十几年前吧
那个CRYTEK引擎的时候
他们就有很多人在做这个东西
他们要精细到什么程度呢
就是说我们在热带地区的植被
它应该是什么一个规则对吧
我到了高纬度寒带地区的植被是什么
东半球是什么
西半球是什么
对吧
它你会发现它的规则都有一些细微的变化
包括比如说我们用这种方法自动生成
比如像城市对吧
那其实不同的这个亚洲风格的城市
日本风格对吧
比如说这个这个欧美风格
欧洲风格和美国的这个大都市风格
都完全不一样
所以的话呢这里面其实真的钻研下去
就会非常的有意思
那么其实呢刚才讲了这些这么多东西啊
实际上他都不可能一上来
全部写到我们的word action里面
对不对
那这个时候的话呢我们就明白
我们需要用plugin这个机这个机制
那事实上在大量的商业游戏的
商业软件的这个实践中
我们都会用这个plugin这个机制
比如像著名的qt对不对
然后呢像这个浏览器
像我们的ARREAL都是用这个插件的结构
那么实际上的话我们再回头看
我当我们去构建一个word extra的时候
你会发现啊
你看到的是一个矩阵
这个矩阵里面的话呢有两个维度
一个维度是什么呢
各个系统
比如说mesh的编辑系统对吧
particle的系统对不对
我们还有这个动画的系统诶
你会发现它正好和我们以前讲object component里面
一个个的component类型发生了这样的一个勾连
对不对
诶其实里面还有一个纵向的维度是什么呢
比如说我要编辑一个NPC对吧
我要编辑环境
你们的这种像bird这种
我们叫做那个叫做这个这个群
叫种群
叫群
就是那个就一群物种呢叫那个词叫什么叫herb
还叫什么一个词的那个系统对吧
比如说哎我们还要做其他的天空这样的系统
那你会发现也就是说这个纵向的这个呃
横纵纵向的这个各种类型的物体
和横向的各个系统之间形成一个交叉矩阵
那我问大家一个问题
那如果我们要给一个word editor设计plugin的时候
我们到底是应该按照这个纵向的
object类型的去切分
还是按照横向的
就是说各个系统进行切换
比如说party system来进行切换
那其实这个问题的答案呢是都要
这也是今天我这节课想跟大家具体讲一下
就what editor里面plugin在设计的时候
大家需要考虑的问题
因为实际上举个例子
比如说party system
大家想想看
当我做好了一个word的架构的时候
party system是不是最好用plug init形式单独做
不要把它变成word or的一个内嵌功能
因为你可能有各种各样的party
比如说我做了一个普通的一个系统
对不对
我今天发现显卡特别的强
我想实现一个GPU driven的particle
叫GPU particle
那么GPU particle呢
它可能会和一般的particle有一点点区别
那最简单的做法是什么
我要通过一个plugin干
将来对吧
我的形式会发生变化
那么那个但是的话呢
比如说今天我要做一个这个
就是说诶一个NPC的行为
那NPC行为的话
它实际上可能当我想这个插件我想写的是说诶
你可以直接选择这个NPC的职业年龄
他的所属的这个这个这个他的行为模型好
这个时候我想影响的是什么呢
诶我要影响的是我要随机给它一个外观
我要随机他一个性格
我要我甚至要影响他的animation
他的AS的所有的行为对吧
包括他可以交互的东西
所以说其实啊在一个真正的word editor里面的话
我们实际上要支持这种矩阵性性的
这个数据的支撑访问
让任何一个plugin能够纵向的
横向的都要去对这个世界进行进行影响
这里面就回到一个非常有意思的问题了
就是说大家如果学过这个软件工程的话
应该知道就plugin其实有很多种模型对吧
那这里面有大名鼎鼎的
比如说覆盖模型
对不对
就是说我新版本的plugin
就能够把老的这个plugin的功能全部盖掉
直接用我的功能
那这个东西在游戏引擎有没有用
当然有用了
对不对
比如说我今天要做一个地形编辑O引擎
原神提供了一个版本
但是呢今天我要做一个这个地形编辑的话呢
我希望我想做一个像小小星球这样的一个东西
就是我希望整个地区地面全是curve的
然后呢哎我呢是能形成一个SOPHIA
这样的话我的所有的摆放都在上面可以去做
那这个时候就意味着什么呢
哎意味着你的这个新的地形的plugin
最好能够覆盖掉以前那个老的party
你可是你要解决的问题我是完全不一样的对吧
那么他在parking还有一个模式是什么呢
我们叫做这个啊
Distribute
就是说所有的plugin都是独自工作
每个人解决自己的问题
互相不影响
最后结果合到一起
那这个这个模型就更不用讲了
大家想象一下在我们的word editor里面
是不是大部分的plug in都是这样的
比如说我做particle的对吧
就跟那个地形没有太大关系
对不对
那我是做那个就是说其他的打光
我比如说做那个light的这个部署的plugin
可能跟这个particle又没有什么太大关系对吧
所以其实的话呢我们的plugin
大部分时候
大家感受到的其实都是这种分布式的
就大家分分头自己把活干完就合到一起来去
来那个分公式的
然后最后形成几个协作的这样一个机制啊
这种模型我们是不是在word里面都要用到
对吧好
那这个时候还有一种著名著名的方法叫pipeline
就是我的数据一个串一个一个串一个
那我们在做这个这个editor会不会用到呢
唉实话实说
我们会用到
为什么呢
当我们进行这种数据处理和导出的时候
打个比方
比如说我们要做一个物理这个物理的效果
那物理的效果它的前面的东西是什么呢
我要对这个世界进行partition
就是比如对一个对象进行几何的切割
对吧
我希望用一个几何的插件
形成我想要的碎片的类型
那这个呢我的物理的那个pk
更多的只是设置它的物理属性
那这个时候实际上我的那个几何的那个plugin
插进来之后
它的输出输出就是我的输出
而它呢会插在我前面
先对数据进行处理
那么最后一个这就是洋葱圈了
洋葱圈的意思就是说
哎我要和别的pokey进行输入和输出
同时操作
那这件事情听上去好像有点抽象了对吧
那这么复杂的结构我们会用吗
刚才我讲的那个比如像rule system对吧
他其实就是有点像杨同学
为什么他几乎会和所有的plugin都会talk
他要读那个地形的笔刷的那个plugin对吧
他要读那个地形
他要读什么呢
所有的decorator那个plugin就是刷direct
director的plugin对吧
他需要那个读那个所有的那个tree啊
foliage的这个plugin我都要读诶
我根据我读来的数据之后呢
我自己对它进行处理
处理完之后我还把结果反过来写回去
改写你们的状态
所以这里面我想跟大家讲的东西是什么呢
就是说今天当我们真的站在一个引擎的视角
去架构一个就是world editor或者各种各样的editor的时候
大家在你的设计结构上
一定要保持一种很强的开放性
因为当一个真实的游戏production的需求来
他对工具的要求的话
实际上各种plugin的模型它都会用到
所以千万不要上来
先给个假设
说
我要求所有的BGIN都怎么怎
么按这个模式去走啊
至少以我个人的工程实践来讲的话
我觉得这事好像搞不定对
所以说有的时候我想就是做软件工程
有的时候真的就是在啊
我认为在两个很精分的需求中间达到一个平衡
就是说我们去追求这个软件体系的那种
严谨性和一致性
但是的话呢我们要理解工程上我为了解决问题
其实我明白我的scenario非常的复杂
所以我必须要妥协
我必须要允许很多种不同的pattern
在我的系统中能够和谐地共存
所以这里面就讲到一个很有意思的问题
就是最近我们哦
你知道我们程序员万年不变的话题是哪个语言
是世界上最好的语言对吧
那么有的时候我们会看到有些评论说
哎这个从学术上讲
这个语言设计的不够elegant
就是不够优雅
然后我作为一个工程师的话
作为一个码农
我就很不屑于这句话
我说优雅有什么用呢
一点用处都没有对吧
他不能解决我的问题
所有能帮我解决问题的语言
他都是好语言
所以说其实当我们去研究这个plugin的设计
pattern的时候
我们我我会建议大家
秉持着这种实用主义的原则
任何一个架构只要能解决我们的问题
那就是个好的架构
其实plugin里面的话呢
其他的问题其实真的是非常的复杂
举个例子
就是说
当我们一个庞大的一个游戏引擎体系
发育起来之后
你会发现引擎的内核你会不停的升级对吧
你的版本结构
你的数据我会升级
但是呢你很多plugin它并不能够严格的保证
按照你的这个版本结构进行升级
对不对
那这个时候最理想的情况当然是
我每次引擎一升级
所有的plugin全部升级一遍对吧
但这件事情其实做不到
特别是对于那种大型的商业引擎
那么都有成千上万的人为他写插件
那这个时候这些插件的不同版本的兼容性
将会是一个非常大的问题
所以这也是希望大家在一开始设计这些接口
的时候
就要考虑的清楚
比如说我们对接口进行版本编号
你这个pk只用了我这样的一些SDK的话
这个SDK是有个版本号的
那个版本号只要不变的话
你的plugin我认为是有效的
但是如果我发现我要变了的话
我就无效
但是呢这里面有一个很很难的挑战是什么呢
就是说作为引擎的研发者的时候
你虽然开放出这些接口
你根本不知道那些plugin的老哥
是怎么去用这些接口的
很可能他用了一个你完全想不到的方式
这个把这个接口
这个这个去修改了你内部的数据好
你也不知道
当你对你内部的结构进行升级的时候
那个老哥的东西可能直接就崩掉了
但你认为我的接口函数没有变啊
我柯南给你做的服务都提供了呀
那我为什么会崩掉呢
但有的时候你就会产生这样的问题
所以简单来讲的话呢
就是说其实一个好的
就是一个引擎的设计的话呢
在这个地方是特别能够体现出它的功力的
这一点上
我实话实说
我认为还是蛮难的
非常难
所以同学们在一开始去加个游戏引擎的时候呢
也不要对自己提那么高的要求
说句实话
至少pica没有认真的考虑这个问题
我们做的还是比较简单的
因为怕同学们太难
但是呢当你从业
比如说五到10年左右的时候
诶
你确实可以认真地考虑这个问题
我个人认为就是说呃编程10年以下的话
考虑这个问题为时过早
真的就是我自己一直认为
就是说我不认为我不建议
就是程序员写了几年代码之后
就觉得我要做管理
实际上技术开发了很多东西的话
你没有10年到20年的沉淀的话
很多时候你很难理解他的这种复杂度
它能体系的那个丰富度
所以的话呢架构真的是我认为架构师是程序员
程序员的终极归宿吧
OK好
那这就是这个我们讲这个
这次详细的结合我们的word editor
跟同学们讲了一下这个plugin这个结构
那接下来呢给大家讲个有意思的东西了
就是说诶我们在游戏中的话
怎么样去表达一种线性的这个叙事性的东西
因为其实啊在就是我们讲在游戏中啊
一个最重要的挑战是什么呢
我们叫做startling对吧
其实我经常嘲笑
就是很多3A游戏做到后来他不是游戏了
它就是个交互电影
确实是虽然我个人是觉得哎呀这不是游戏啊
这违反了游戏的精神
但实话实说
我作为一个玩家
我还是很enjoy的
而且这让我云游戏起来一点都没有罪恶感
我觉得这个游戏我就不需要买了
我云完了之后
这个游戏80%以上的内容我已经知道了
为什么我还辛苦自己受苦
完成了剩下的20%的交互部分呢
所以说但是呢这不妨碍就是说在游戏世界里面
我们的叙事非常的重要
你们可以看到
就是我们的游戏做的越来越像电影
就是每一个镜头
每一个角色的动作
每一个光每一次爆炸对吧
每一次这个这个入场都是被精心设计过
而这一切的东西发生在哪里呢
它其实啊是发生在一个时间轴上
也就是说在这个时间轴里面诶
到什么时候我开播放什么一个背景音
这个时候我应该播放什么样的一个爆炸的效果
诶这个时候我应该希望角色做一个什么
比如说打招呼或者开枪的这样的一个动作对吧
或者说躲进掩体的一个动作
那这个时候其实啊你会发现我们有大量的元素
或者parameter
是在时间上在发生了这样的一个变化
那这里面的话呢我就举一个例子
因为这个东西讲的有点抽象
那我就用一个比较看得见摸得着的例子
就是大家看到虚幻五里面
虚幻里面很重要的概念叫sequencer对吧
在这里面的话呢
其实呢它对于每一个物体在这个世界里
object的变化
我定义了一个东西叫什么呢
叫track
它当然在虚幻里我们叫做actor了对吧
那在这个track里面的话呢
实际上我们对它的每一任何一条属性
都可以定义一个在时间轴上的变化
然后呢
当我们把这些变化集中在一个时间timeline上的话
我设定了一些叫ky friend的东西
就是它每个关键的变化节点
我在这个key friend之间差值
你用线性也好
你用那个就是那个QQ差距也好
那都是我们的选择
那这些东西结合在一起
我们就形成了一个sequence
那么这个sequence的话呢
实际上我们就可以用这些简单的东西
最后展现出一个让你觉得很丰富的
这样的一个世界
其实你可以理解成就是说我今天要拍一部电影
那我们正常的想法就是诶你有三个演员对吧
好123action
所有人开始说话
对话动作对不对
但是在游戏世界里面
这件事情是非常难的
我们怎么做
我们会这样做
OK演员一
OK你的动作是走到桌前拿起书开始读
然后呢
这个整个时间是多少秒
是五秒
好
这个走到桌子是几秒
那个拿起书是几秒
读是几秒
诶
这个2号演员你你你要做什么
你要坐到椅子上开始张口说一段话
这段话说的几秒几秒好
2号演员全部按照要求做了
第33万元呢是坐在他对面
坐下来也开口讲话好
当我把这三个演员的timeline align套一起之后
诶
你发现当我一点一个播放的时候
你看到的画面就是有一个演
有演员一在认真读书
演员二和演员三
在图书馆坐在椅子上开始聊天
你看到的东西是在同时发生
但是呢真正在游戏世界里面
这些东西是一次一次一次一个个去做的
这个设计非常的有意思
这就是我经常跟大家讲
就是为什么游戏这么难做
就是作为用户来讲的话
你看到的一件事儿都是诶好像顺理成章
就是应该这样
但是在游戏这个引擎和游戏世界里面的话
所有的东西我们都要用零和一
用一行行脚本
一行行代码
让他一个一个要素的生成
当这些要素合到一起的时候
还要非常的合理
你觉得这个事情符合你对自然的认知
所以我经常讲就是我们是躲在零一之后
或者说我们是躲在像素之后的人
那么这里面就举一个很简单的例子
就比如说我们如何让一个小鸡在这里面动起来
对吧
那以按L为例的话
你首先是要把这个小鸡绑在这个
这个就是object上面去
你绑到audio
那接下来诶我这边有个动画
它也播放不了
我们后面可以播放一下
那么接下来的话呢
就是说哎我们实际上要这个用一个东西
我来用一下鼠标来
我回到上一个吧
就是我先把这个小鸡绑到绑成一个track对吧
这个时候的话呢
哎我这个小鸡就开始可以定义他的行为了
然后呢我把他的transform把它的位移绑上去
它就有了一个叫property track
好来
这个时候的话呢
唉我们构建了这样的一个property check的时候
我们把这个transform绑上去之后
诶第三件事情我们就可以做了
第三件事情我们可以做的是什么呢
哎我们可以给这个小鸡
它是在每个不同的位置设置一个k free关键帧
大家如果看完我们动画的话
就觉得这个太简单了对吧
我也知道啊
不就是个位移吗
我设置一个一个在第一个时间轴上放在一个位
一个位置
第二时间轴放到第二个位置
那你这个沿着时间轴一走
它不就形成了一个差值了吗
对很简单
那这个时候如果我对小鸡希望形
形成一个路径的规划的话呢
那我就可以非常的简单
那我实际上就可以让他在几个K分之间
来回走来走去
实际上你可以看到就是说在各个关系中
我们改的到底是什么呢
就是它的一个component的一个parameter
就是transform
它的位置可以来一句
但这里面这个case非常的简单
这个小鸡看上去特别特别的傻
但是呢同学们我们看到的游戏里面
那些刚才我一上来放的那个视频中
比如说那个黑黑客
那个黑客帝国reload里面的那些酷炫的表演
实际上就是一个一个角色
一个个效果在这个timeline上表达出来的
包括像刚才那个战地那个视频里面
你看到哇真的是很棒对吧
很精彩
所有的事情都在发生
但实际上呢这就是很多个设计师
他在一帧就是一个K分
一个分成员
一个object一一个object把它序列放好
最后我们看到的这样的一个结果
所以其实这个东西啊
对于整个游戏的工具体系来讲是非常重要的
就是工具体系实际上有一大类的需求
就是在时间轴上去让parameter动起来
或者让对象动起来
这里面不止讲的是剧情
包括我们讲的生效
包括我们讲的游戏里面的一些UI对吧
其实UI的话很多时候你点一个东西
它后来发生了一系列的事情
比如说那个比如说举个例子啊
比如说你你暴击了一个人对吧
产生了一系列的什么击杀头衔
包括你who kill了谁对吧
暴击率是多少
包括对对
我能看的见面
这一切全是在一个时间轴上去发生的
就UI体系里面也有大量的这种
基于timeline的这样的一个顺序
所以我们举了sequencer作为一个例子
就是让同学们知道
就是说其实你看到那些复杂的这种线性的
沿着时间轴的交互
它都是这样的一个体系
就是说用了一个体系叫timeline
然后timeline里面的话
我们修改各个对象的这个属性
那么UI控件的话也是一样的
你供它属性
那你控制那个光源
控制天空那个的光照
你控制这个你现在场景
你甚至这个一下子可以切换场景对吧
其实很多过场动画还是偷偷的
把场景都会换掉的
那么也是用了这样的一套架构来去发声
在这里面引出我们非常有趣的一个话题
是什么呢
就是反射和games play
为什么大家看啊
其实刚才我讲的那个sequencer这个体系的话
它最核心的就是在时间轴上去调了
以前component里的几个parameter
对不对
那这件事是怎么做到的
就是我怎么我的工具是怎么知道去修改
那个RUNTIME里面那个对象的那个数据呢
我这个中间链接是怎么建立起来的
当然知道我们有schema
对schema只是帮你描述了
但是你得找到那个数据啊
你得set and get
对不对
你首先知道他当前的数据
你还要去改它的数据
哎
这里面就引入了我们很重要的就是reflection
可以说reflection也是sequencer的一个foundation之一好
那么实际上的话呢就是在我们在做game play的时候
其实你会发现在游戏中的game play
是非常丰富和复杂的
而且我今天作为一个引擎的话
其实我根本不会知道啊
未来基于这个引擎开发的各种各样的游戏的话
它会有什么样的一种EMPLAY
比如说在这里面举个例子
我希望有个激光对吧
我顶上去之后它能发生什么事情
它能够射出一根箭
这根箭能够拉动
有什么东西
这些东西不可能写到引擎里面
对不对
那说同学们会说没关系啊
我们可以用数据配置把这个逻辑配出来
实际上你会发现有的是玩法
它是用数据配不出来的对吧
就是说任何语言它的表达都是有上限的
数据本身也是一种语言嘛
那怎么办
我们要允许就是说那个我们的游戏开发团队
基于这个引擎不断地扩展它的玩法
不断不断增加新的接口
新的功能对吧
哎这个工具我要必须要要要来支持他
那这个时候实际上大家最熟悉的东西就来了
就是说哎我们各种各样的
就是基于visual的这种script语言
其实呢大家很熟悉的叫blue print了
blue print只是这个visual script语言的一种
实际上大家看我们现在的很多的引擎
包括一些游戏之外的应用里面
都会用到这样的一个方法
什么意思呢
这个东西其实从某种意义上有点我们叫做啊
有点像现在很流行的一个概念
叫做低代码或者零代码开发
也就是说你不需要用代码
你就可以构建你的东西
那么在游戏这里面的话呢
我们实话实说
我们处理的情况是最最复杂的
在游戏引擎里面
那么在游戏引擎里面
我们设计这样一个visual scripting语言
我们最核心要解决的问题是什么
那么实际上是这个是呃
可视化编程语言的可扩展性
道理很简单
如果这个编程语言是预设预设好的
各种节点对吧
然后我只是去开放各种接口
让你连接这件事情难不难
你其实有点挑战
但是呢可以做不难
但是他有个很大的缺陷是什么
就是说
就像我今天我要去加一个新的feature的时候
那我今天假设左边定义了一个角色
他就跳的这个一个角色对吧
那我在右边的话
就需要在我的可视化节点代码中就说诶好
我知道每个人类有一跳这样的动作
那我明天说不好意思
我支持了这个角色
他还可以这个停止跳这个动作
那我是不是在工具这一层也要再加一行代码
使得工具里面那个那个节点
他要增加一个一个接口
而且它能正确地调用那个函数
这个调用函数我一般我们叫做invoke对吧
那这样的话
实际上你会发现
就是说我们在这个一旦增加了游戏逻辑之后
我那边就会要不停的去修改我的工作单位
当然我可以通过那个C加加的派生和继承
我只是不会用每次改它的基本结构
我只是派生一个新类
我可以支持这个事儿
但是工具那边的话就会变得非常的复杂
这就是一个不可扩展
不可维护的东西
所以这个时候呢大家最喜欢的东西就来了
就是说诶反射
反射呢其实是游戏高级语言里面
一个非常常用的一个概念
这也是最近这些年啊
我觉得语言一个很大的情况
因为在早期的语言比较像汇编对吧
比如像C加
我们是没有反射的
对不对
大家什么东西都是我们上来手写我的
我的感觉就有点像那个
我记得我以前在读书的时候
我们在幻想一种画面
就是半夜寝室里面那个亮的灯
有人在拿着小刀在光盘上刻出一个操作系统
对吧
因为操作大家知道那个早期的那个存储
它都是那一个个那个词典嘛
我们只在YY那种最土法炼钢的感觉
但是呢其实那些比如像汇编啊
比如说像C语言啊
这些语言确实是他没有反射
它实际上它就是一段非常native的代码
扔给机器就跑了
但是呢实际上当我们到java
到c#这种高级语言的时候
实际上我们全面的都支持了反射
反射
实际上也就意味着说
当我写黄银行代码之后
实际上系统会告诉我说
你到底有哪些新的功能被暴暴露出来
这样的话当我们这个其他的调用者
它并不需要跟你的代码链接编译到一起
它实际上就可以
这个知道能够调取这些新的功能接口的入口
这个是一个非常重要的一个
一个现代语言的一个拓展
而且这在工程上来讲的话
其实我记得我在呃是很早很早以前
我们在最早架前几代引擎的时候
因为我们没有用高级语言嘛
就是引擎里面我们都是用那个CC和C加加
然后我们用了很多很奇怪的这个模板的hack
其实它的核心目的是什么呢
就是因为找到类似这种反射的感觉
就是诶我定了一个结构
定义了一些方法
我外面的接口我能够不需要跟你重新编译
我就能把你的方法找到
我就能调用
你等我们有了反射之后
我们就知道
哎呀我们这些工作到后来全是无用功
那么反射怎么做呢
唉其实呢反射啊
这个待会我再讲反射怎么做啊
其实反射我们认为呢
它实际上就是在代码和工具之间
在引擎里面构建了一个很好的桥梁
就是我的引擎实现了一些功能
它写好了之后
我通过网反射
我生成一个表
告诉我说你这个引擎开放了哪些类的接口
有哪些功能
有哪些数据
你可以访问
并且生成了一堆的这个诶invoke
你去调用它的函数
一堆的这种set and get
你可以修改和改变它的变量
这个时候等我写工具的时候就会非常的简单
比如说我写一个我的脚本语言
我定义了一个
我发现你们你定义了一个功能叫做人啊
这个人有很多属性对吧
比如说他的身高体重
他的血量唉
我都可以set and get
然后呢我发现你可以让他走跑跳诶
这些功能我都有
那当我在我的可视化脚本语言里面
我创建一个节点叫做人的时候
它的所有的这些属性参数
节点全部都可以这个显示出来
而且还有一点什么呢
我们知道我知道它的类型是什么意思
就是说哎比如说像那个走跑跳是一个动作
那我就可以去invoke它
它可能是个三角形的标记
就这个节点你动作流可以走过来
那么他如果是属性的话呢
它是个property诶
我可以显示它
我甚至可以编辑它
我可以找一个modifier
可以可以修改它
比如说我把你的血量减伤这个武器的伤害
最后得再重新得到你的一个新的血量
我用一个脚本
用一个简单的贴那个那个visual scripting的这个图
就可以把这个算法给写出来
大家会说诶我作为一个程序员
这个东西让我去写个代码会更简单
而且更好
第八个对不对
为什么你要用这种visual scripting的方法去解解决呢
这件事情的话其实让我也研究和思考了很久
就是我以前一直都不理解
说其实脚本也很方便
我可以对这个引擎功能进行扩展
而且我作为程序用debug写的效率最高对吧
也很方便
而且我还可以def啊
为什么大家后来会用VSCOTT这个语言
那我自己后来的理解是这样
就是说我们作为程序员的话呢
我们天然的会认为这东西很方便
但是对于大量的设计师和艺术家来讲的话
他们光光建立那一套语言的编译环境
包括确保按照你的语法去写
不会出错
这个事情对他的门槛是非常非常高的
他们很多时候需要的是什么
就是这个块拖进来
你看到不同颜色的接口和蓝色的接口
连蓝色的线
红色的接口连红色的线对吧
红色对红色
蓝色对蓝色
三角对三角方块的方块
圆形对圆形
其实对于他们来讲
是一种最自然的一种表达方式
所以的话呢我现在也自己被洗脑了
我认为就是说visual scripting
实际上是引擎未来发展的一个方向
因为它真的能够把引擎
开放给足够多的这个用户
所以r reflection反射就是
如果你们认为这是一个正确的方向的话
它就是构建在引擎和工具之间的
一个重要的一个桥梁
好这个时候我们就讲一个有意思的细节了
我们这个课程一般来讲是不会讲细节的
但今天为什么一定要讲细节呢
因为课程里面的同学们一直在插那句
我们说请请课程组织讲一下
我们那个PICO的反射到底是怎么做的
那今天的话我们就夹带点私货给大家讲一下
就是在C加里面
我们到底是怎么实现这个这个这个反射的
这个事情呢
其实呢讲起来没啥秘密
非常的简单
就是我们实际上大家知道啊
就是我们所有的现代高级语言
他都要通过一个类似GP2规范的这样一个
编译系统
把它编译出去
那么整个编译过程呢也不是我们自己能瞎写的
实际上他也有一套非常规范的pipeline
比如说你前面要进行语法分析
要passing对吧
你要生成这个s st抽象语法树
然后呢你还要对它进行形成一个中间代码
中间代码再生成我们的target code
就是我们机器能跑的
那所以整个这套pipeline
已经在过去的几十年里面
有我们无数的先贤
已经整理总结的非常的完善了
谢天谢地啊
正好还有大量的开源的这样的一个编译器
比如说C浪对吧
它其实非常的好
它可以把你的这个语言翻译成这个这个AST
就抽象语法书
大家仔细观察一下
当我们给你一个C加里面的一个类
和它的变量的定义的时候
你发现没有
他经过了这个这个高C浪的这样的
一个分析之后
它会形成一个非常好被解读的
这样的一个一个一个就是语言的这个表
它其实是树状结构的一个表
而这个表的话
那里面我们就可以很容易地把任何一个类
它的接口的函数
接口的这个就是他的那个member web全部提取出来
其实他这个东西是不区分语言呢
你其他的语言扔进去
它也能处理
那好我们有了这样的一个东西之后
大家想想
我去生成我们想要的这个schema
应该是很简单的对吧
皮克洛呢我们就比较土
我们就选的是那个C浪
C浪
为什么选C浪呢
其实有很多原因了
第一个它看源本身
而且很模块化
你可以自由的加载
而且呢它本身也是一个非常稳定成熟
也是被最广泛验证过的这么一个平台
所以呢我们PGA的选择就是选择一个A
大家觉得最简单最可靠的一个插件吧
但我个人认为C浪是个很好的选择
大家甚至如果有兴趣的话
也可以通过这个皮克拉
你们怎么去用这个C浪的话
也能知道PC浪最简单的一个用法好
那么其实呢
那我们当我们把这个C加的代码
拿来处理的时候
我们实际上就可以生成我们的schema对吧
这个schema
但是大家注意啊
就是在PICO里面的话呢
我们并没有显示的把这个schema文件存出来
我们只是在内存中定义了一个四维码
大家可以找到那个数据结构好
那其实呢这个在讲一个细节
就是说实际上呢反射呢比大家想象的
要有一些更精准的控制
为什么呢
因为我们一个引擎代码对吧
就算提高了有几万行代码
那你们可能有几百个
甚至上应该有几百个数据结构
我并不是所有的数据结构我都需要反射的
对不对
我们实际上很多时候是需要和资源打交道的
数据才要反射
那怎么办呢
哎我们通过定义一些描述词
大家注意到在pillar里面有两个描述词
第一种叫做那个class
定义一个类
那个红写了一个红啊
然后这里面说我后面写了个FS
什么意思
就是说我这个class里面所有的member variable
都要被反射出来
唉这个看上去没毛病对吧
但是呢实际上我们在定义有些累的时候呢
我们并不希望所有的memorable都要被反射出来
为什么呢
因为有些变量并不需要跟内存啊
并不需要跟磁盘之间就文件之间交换
它实际上是我计算中间结果有这个有这个需求
对不对
诶
你在后面加个描述词叫什么呢
哎就是white list only对吧
这样我就知道了哦
那这个类里面的话呢虽然有十个不同的
慢慢吧
举个例子啊
但是呢只有我看到的叫meta enable
那个那个描关键词的时候
我就知道哦
这些东西我要把它反射成我想要的那个
那个数据
那这东西怎么实现的呢
这里面讲一个细节
这里面就不好意思讲个细节了
其实这个东西实际上是通过宏来
实际上大家如果对C加加语言有了解的话
你会发现其实我们的编译器
我如果是真的编译它ex e的时候
这些所有的描述全部都是无效的
但是呢如果我们去编译它的这个
reflection的时候
我要获取reflection的时候
实际上我的if define
把它define成那样的一个标标识
但这里面注意就是说在那个C浪
它提供了一个方法
就是你可以定义一个
attribute的一个特殊关键词
ash里面有一种类型叫做annotation
就是标记
然后呢你可以把各种标记打进去
那你在你最后生成的SD代码里面
他会给你生成叫那个tribute的括号annotation
然后把你的文字放进去
我们只要检测到这个东西的时候
我们就知道哦
你下面到底想让我干什么
所以大家仔细看
看上去非常神秘啊
一个C代码放在这
我就能生成所有的反射啊
这些东西
但实际上它就是一个非常简单的
就是我成员叫字符游戏吧对吧
大家会发现就是编程
程序员到最后对字符的非常的敏感
就是因为就是呃我我分享一个小故事
就是程序员到后来基本上都有强迫症
因为程序员对什么这个缩进啊
什么时候打逗号啊
比如说大括号
到底同行不同行都非常的这个geek
都甚至为此会这么有劲对吧
两方吵的面红耳脸红
脖子粗
实际上就是因为我们的这个职业属性
会让我们对这些东西特别的敏感
就是因为你看到所有精妙的游戏啊
这些东西它本质上它都是一个字符游戏而已
所以说这里面的话就跟大家讲一些细节
就是让第一次让大家明白
就是皮克拉的反射到底是怎么做的
其实皮克勒的反射的话还蛮具有代表性的
比如说大家想如果想学习一下unreal的反射
怎么做的话呢
荣耀虽然比我们做的复杂
但是它基础的方法和结构跟这个非常接近好
那么其实这里面的话呢
诶讲完了这个反射之后
大家就知道了哦
那我我给一段C加代码
只要加上你的这些特殊的标记
我就能够自动找到你们所有偶像的结构
这是没错的
而且我还能生成它的schema描述
这也没有问题
但是呢这还不够
因为我的工序我要大量的去访问
修改这里的数据
调用你们的方法
对不对
所以呢我们要是每个reflection
我要生成它很多的ACCESSOR
就讲你可以理解成就是三类函数吧
叫get set invoke
对不对
就是我是获取一些数值
改变一些数据
或者我找到一个方法之后
我把这个方法给调用一遍对吧
invoke他一下
那么这个呢就牵扯到一个非常有意思的概念
叫代码渲染
大家想象一下
我们一个引擎需要反射的类可能有几十个
那我把反射做出来之后
那这些函数谁去写呢
如果这个函数变成了
也是需要我程序员去写的话
首先这些代码其实非常的荣誉
第二个不是说好了自动化吗
说好了接口自动生成吗
你为什么又突然又让我去写代码了
所以呢这里面就有个很有意思的工具
叫做代码渲染了
那么这个东西呢其实也不是什么高深的概念
因为实际上在web端的话
大家很早就发现这个问题了
就是我要生成各种各样的页面
但是呢它的逻辑其实是大同小异的
但是呢只是它的数据不一样
那我希望这个前端的代码
它是能自动生成的对吧
比如像这里面我要显示两个不同
UI51改变的是什么
是三里面三个颜色的那个名字
其他东西我一概不变
那这个时候呢
实际上代码渲染是一个非常好的一个工具
其实我现在都几乎找不到他什么缺点
反正它的好处是什么呢
第一个就是说能够大量的减少荣誉代码开发
甚至呢它会减少你犯错
因为渲染出来的代码一次性
第八个通过之后以后很少会出错
就像我们做的那个schema系统的话
其实那个代码放在那差不多也快10年了
但是几乎不出错的
为什么
因为这些代码全是自动生成的
如果出错
他早就出错了
如果不出错
你就写10万行
生成100万行
它也不会出错
那么还有一点是什么呢
它是非常完美的把数据和逻辑进行了分离
就以前我们在写代码的时候
其实有些东西我们认为是数据的东西
那我必须要写进去
对不对
但现在我们可以实现就是数据和逻辑
更加彻底的decoupling
所以代码渲染就是
当我们在架构一个大型系统的时候
我一直认为就是能够通过自动化生成的代码
尽量的自动化生成
不要自己手写
因为手写的过程是不可控的
很容易就是你昨天那个版本写的没有问题
后天那版本写出来就是有问题了
那么在PICO里面的话呢
我们用了一个非常有意思的小工具
就是那个mustache
mustache的那个英文的原意叫什么呢
叫这个胡子
确实因为这个他要求你在描述你的代码的时候
加很多的这个大括号对吧
感觉像这个人套了很多大胡子一样
然后呢他通过你的数据的语法的翻译诶
自动的把你渲染出你想要的代码
这个东西其实非常的简单
而且也是很稳定的一个系统
所以在我们的皮克勒引擎中的话呢
我们也这是我们真正实战的
在内存中生成的这个CHEMA数据
然后呢哎我们写好了这样的一个模板描述
我们就可以自动的生成它各种各样的代码
更具体的细节的话
同学们就可以看
所以同学们今天啊基本上听完这两趴的话
如果大家的技术基础过关的话
基本上就能够猜看懂皮克拉的这个代码生成器
是怎么做的了
他首先就是调这个叫那个C浪对吧
声称我们内存中的schema
然后在生成schema之后呢
我们根据我们预先写好的这些程序的模板
再调master生成我们大量的excel code
这样就能实现我的引擎里面
可以定义任何一个结构
在编辑器里面就能互相看到
对吧好
那么基本上讲到这儿的话
我们的引擎工具链讲完了
就是这些东西
那么当然了
真实的引擎工具是非常复杂的
那我再讲下去的话呢
我觉得我讲的就基本上就是要这个
什么引擎教学课程了对吧
引擎教学课程这个东西说实话我并不擅长
我不是个特别好的引擎的使用者
但是我非常有兴趣
就是架构讨论引擎的架构好
这里面的话呢我在这节课里面呢
我再额外的补充一个小小的一部分
就是说
其实我个人认为就是在现代游戏引擎
有一个很重要的发展方向
叫做协同编辑
为什么呢
因为大家看现在的3A游戏啊
包括我们经常讲开放世界
这个数据量和数据的维度
远远超过我们一个人能够handle的一个
这个这个就是这个能力
那这个时候呢
我们客观上就需要很多人共同编辑
那只要大家一共同编辑啊
这个事情就很头疼
比如说当你要编辑这么大规模的一个一个场景
对吧
你你这个里面有大量的素材
这些素材可能有几十个
甚至上百个artist共同产生
那我们彼此之间怎么样的可以不打架呢
当然我们说我们全部用P4PCC对吧
proceed方法生成对的
这个听上去好像很了不起
但是真正游戏的核心啊
它还是一个叫做novelty
就是就是说它具有一定的这个叫新鲜度
或者说叫做这个就是叫啊生动度了
nobody就怎么创新度
那么这就意味着说
如果一个P7算法足够成熟之后
实际上他的pattern还是会很容易被玩家发现
所以我们还是需要大量的artist
他的灵光一闪的创意
但我这句话说的很有天一点为时过早
说不定那个按照阿拉马斯的想法
2030年我们实现了强人强人工智能
nobody这件事情我们也可以交给那个AI去解决
这是有可能的
那我们的这个工具体系会再重新设计一遍
包括我们很多的artist可能会因此失忆啊
这是个很悲惨的故事
那我们今天我们先假设强人工智能还很遥远
那我们实际上就还需要
就是很多人在一起共同协作
那怎么协作呢
那其实协作的话呢
其实最容易出的问题就是冲突
也就是说我去改了一个东西
和你改的东西发生了冲突
所以呢在传统的做法中呢
我们会把这个场景分成很多很多的不同的文件
然后呢让你编辑完之后
你们去merge对吧
这个做法其实是很笨
但是呢其实也很有效
那在这里面的话呢
就是说我们会把物体进行不同的划分嘛
那里面有三种完全啊
三种独立的这个划分思路
举个例子啊
第一个就是我把世界进行分层
比如说编辑地形的编辑地形
编辑植被的编辑植被
编辑建筑物的编辑建筑物
或者甚至是我的
我在物体里面会区分说
你编辑的是建筑物还是周围的小装饰物对吧
那这样的话呢
每一个不同layer的东西放在不同的分层里面
每一个artist只编辑自己的分子
这样好不好好的
但是呢这里面会出现一个比较大的问题
是什么呢
就是说哎其实这个分层你很难分得特别好
而且呢很多时候不同层
不同层的东西是有相互依赖的
举个例子啊
比如说我们做地形的artist
他做完地形
一旦对地形进行修改之后
那你上面的那些植被
那些东西的排布
是不是相应的都要发生变化对吧
举个最简单的例子
就是说啊我的一个artist改变了这个房子的位置
那你在周边种的所有的树对吧
包括你对地面进行调整
是不是都要相应的发生变化
但如果这件事情是在三个互相看不见的artist
一起来做的话
这个地方就会产生无数的问题
所以分层是一个最古老的方法
很早很早以前引擎就已经支持了
但是的话呢确实也是一个
我们认为在真你真的开始协作的时候
问题其实非常的多
但是我们这个里面有个很土的做法
就是三个artist的轮流做对吧
第一个做完
然后把它的分层锁定
另外一个是基于基于它继续做
这样是可以的
但是你真的想就是同时去做的时候
他很多时候效果就很差
那么好
那么一种更土的做法将来了更有意思
做法就是我对世界进行划分
我分成块一块二块三块四块五对吧好
那这个就很简单
我们就是反正这个地块的事情归你了
那个地块已经归我了对吧
这个事情呢也是非常简单好用
但是它会出现一个有意思的问题是什么呢
就是说我们有很多房子
比如说我就是跨界了
怎么办对吧
比如说我作为一个山脉
我作为一个植被作业
做一个分布一一个湖湖泊
我很可能会跨两个界
所以那我是不是要支持不规则的世界画面
其实这件事情啊在那个真实世界里面很存在
举个例子吧
比如说我们我我以前看过很多
那个就是有意思的旅行的这个小小小文章
大家讲在很多欧洲国家的那个国际上
有一栋房子
左边属于一个国家
右边属于国家对吧
那你这个怎么去解决这个房子归属的问题呢
对吧
包括有一些山也是这样的
一些河流也是这样
所以说其实这个对世界的划分
很多时候啊是一个非常有效的
它能解决很多问题
但是呢在有些地方他又很难解决这个一些cross
这个boundary这些case怎么解决
但是呢我们在看一个场景
特别是一玩家去看一个场景
它是连续的
所以说如果这个世界真的是割裂的时候
如果你感觉到边界那边很明显的区别的话
很多时候艺术家啊
玩家是接受不了了
当然了
这里我们有很多方法
比如说最后再来一波artist
对边界这个地方在进行专门的修理
这也是可以的
所以这个方法的话也是一个非常简单的使用的
一个方法
那么另外一个呢下面给大家只是提一下吧
这个因为也是现在刚刚在推出的一些技术
比如像unreal five最近推的这个one file projector
就是OFPA
他这个就很极端了
他说你们既然觉得这个世界容易冲突
对不对
好游戏世界里面每个对象
我就给你创建一个文件对吧
你们每个人只改自己的文件
你们彼此再也不会冲突了
这个听上去非常的了不起
我个人觉得也是非常了不起的
一个一个一个尝试
但是呢这个就是我自己也是简单看了一下
OFPA吧
就是包括我们团队也在交流
就是说他的问题它会产生无数的小文件
当然其实他也不会那么傻
他会做做了很多机制对于小文件进行管理
但这个事实上的话
那就会产生两个比较现实的问题
就是说当我进行版本管理的时候
比如说我地形这个我这个场景做完之后
我要去提交一个新的版本的时候
我发现我要提交很多很多的文件
这个大家如果用过真正的source control的软件
你就知道source Ctrl软件的话
比如像p four
比如像SBN对吧
如果你一下子做大量文件的版本管理的话
这个对他们来讲就很痛苦
他们到最后你会发现整个工作室都卡住了
卡不动
更新不了这个数据
包括就是我们在cooking的时候
因为我这些碎文件我不能在内存中
就是也是这么多碎文件
这个到时候会让我的游戏的性能特别低
所以呢它实际上在cooking的时候呢
要把这些所有文件还是打包到我的
一个level的文件里面去
那这样的话呢
就会使得在我在对数据进行打包的时候
有了一个额外的过程
而且这个时候你面对的可能是上万的
这种小文件
大家如果对操作系统有所了解的话
你会发现操作系统最恨什么东西呢
最恨的就是小文件
所以的话呢
这会产生很多的额外的这样的一个负载
所以这个技术呢但我个人认为就是虚幻
提出来肯定是有它的道理的
就是说他一定我们想到东西
他也也想到了
所以实际上的话
我认为这也是个非常值得大家关注的一个
前沿的方向
因为这里面我讲的每一个问题
它总是有一些技术方法可以绕过去的
而这个方法确实是能彻底的解决
就是协同编辑里产生冲突问题
当然了
这里面我讲的是协同编辑里面
最简单的就是哎
我们几个人各自编辑在一起合的
实际上协同编辑啊
我们的终极状态是什么呢
我们同时在编辑
也就是说张三李四王五在编辑的时候
彼此之间都能看到
而这个时候呢实际上就要有一套网络的架构
就是说一般来讲我们是在局域网里面
就是说在工作室里面
内网的性能非常高
诶我编的东西别人都能看到
这里面真正的难度呢其实不是状态的同步
难度是什么呢
保持它的语义的高度一致性
大家还记得
我们在这个就是上一节课里面讲到一个概念
就是那个啊
诶稍等
就是上节课我们讲的就是说一个叫command的概念
对不对
我们我就讲过
就是说我们在做这个工具系统做编辑的时候
我们实际上争取把用户的每一个操作
比如说一个拖动
一个选取一个平移对吧
一个改颜色
一个改材质
一个改一个参数
包括sequence里面每一个key frame对吧
K分的增加删除全部变成原子化的操作
变成一个command
然后呢我们在不同的大家所有人的电脑上
我同步你的command
这样的话的好处就是说能够让这个协同编辑
就真的能够去写了这件事情
我讲起来其实非常简单
其实我们将来这一趴
准备的PPT页数是蛮多的
后来被我全部删掉了
因为确实讲起来就太深太复杂了
真的是很难讲
那么但是呢它的核心就是说
你要对整个编辑操作进行原子化处理
实际上是你协同编辑的一个基础
如果你没有这样的一个基础的话呢
那你所谓的协同编辑它一定是个hack
就是你可能看到大概上看上去很像那么回事
但是当艺术家真的用的时候
他会发现很多地方违反了人的直觉
这个是这个东西非常的有意思
就是人对很多协同
就比如说他的直觉
就像是几个小朋友在一起在画布上画画一样的
那么他会认为比如说你画了个蓝色
我画一个紫色
如果你蓝色先画下去
我紫色再画下去
我的紫色穿过你蓝色的区域
就应该把你覆盖掉
因为我在你的后面
对不对
然后这个时候
另外一个小朋友再点了一个绿色的点
诶
他那个点可能点了一半在蓝色区域
一半在紫色区好
这时候那个画紫色的那个那个那个小伙伴
他又说我想暗度一下
我觉得我刚才做的不好
哎呀这个问题就来了
那这个点的那个那个那个绿色的点
和那个那条红色的那个杠子杠子之间的话
他们之间到底有什么关系
其实呢这也是我们认为
就是说做协同编辑非常难的一个问题
是怎么解决undo redo对吧
包括呢怎么让不同的operation没人进行
那这里面的话呢其实有很多啊
非常前沿的一些设计吧
就是说那我们先讲一个最简单的做法
比如说我加各种锁
比如说一个对象
我给他加个锁对吧
这是很自然的
就是二例子说这一篇东西都是我的了
是所有的意思都被我锁上了
好你们不能编辑了
那很好
大家肯定没有冲突对吧
但是这里面所会产生竞争了
那么还有一种呢
就是说哎这个资源是我的
你不能动啊
这个有的时候是有用的
那举个例子
比如说啊我去做一个模型
这个模型的话
我现在打算改它的材质
但我不希望其他人再去改它的材质
因为我们彼此之间会冲突
那我就会显示的告诉你这个资源
我锁上了这个信号
可以以几10ms的速度瞬间同步给别人
但是呢即使有这样的两个锁的话
实际上你在处理它的安do redo的时候
还是有非常多的问题
因为有的时候你创建了一个一个instance
你对它进行编辑
然后别人觉得你成分很好
这棵树很好
对你的树又进行了其他调整
然后呢你过了一会儿就觉得这个数不对
你想用再重新种棵树
你把那个树诶那个按度一下对吧
那可能那个老师做的所有操作
可能当场就会崩掉
所以这其实是我们在做这个编辑的时候
是特别复杂的一个问题
那这里面当然也有一些pattern了
比如说去OT对吧
operating那个这个transform的方法对吧
其实非常的理论很难
比如说像我们真正在引擎
你们经常用的叫CRTT这个方法
就是说哎我们希望通过一套规则体系
让这个conflict变成free
然后呢可以
但是呢他让各个状态
在各个就是那个终端那边都能同步
但这里面展开了就非常的细节了
但这个其实我也跟大家讲过
就说其实协同编辑是一个
在理论上非常热的一个领域
因为现在随着网络的普及啊
就协同操作是一个越来越重要的需求
那么比如我在上节课讲到的
就是像文本编辑对吧
大家用的各种各样的网上的文本编辑器
已经是越来越成熟了
大家还记得早期的时候我印象特别深
早期最早我用google doc的时候
google doc功能是蛮限制的
当时第一次我们发现
我们彼此能看见对方的边界的时候
实际上就还是很震撼的
那么今天的话呢协同编辑
比如像他PS啊
用的做的非常好了
已经很成熟了
大家可以看到
但这个过程是非常非常的漫长
那么其实的话呢
就是现在的协同编辑里面的话呢
我们有很多种flow在一起
也会就是说竞争
比如说现在我们会比较推荐的是什么呢
就是说诶你把所有的操作不要直接apply
它的最终结果
先找一个server
把所有的操作全在一起
结算完之后再统一的发挥给大家
这就有点像什么呢
有点像我们以前做的那个网络架构里面
cs模型
就是说所有的客户端只是发起你的动作
然后你不要操作有server统一结算完之后
把最终的结果返回给每个client
你们自己去看对吧
那你们有至少这个问题的好处是什么呢
你没有争议
你付出的代价是一点点的延迟
但这个东西的话呢
在一个局域网的情况下是可以接受的
这其实也是现在这个很多协同编辑的
就是这个那个那个游戏引擎的话
会采用的这样的一个结构
但这里面可能会带来的一个
有意思的问题是什么呢
就是说那个如果客户端那台机器炸了
没关系
大家就炸了对吧
但是如果被选做服务器的
那个那个那个艺术家的机器
假设炸掉之后
那一群人直接就崩掉了
所以这个系统的健壮性和鲁棒性的话呢
其实也还是有一些东西需要去设计一下的
所以这件事情的话呢
我认为还在一个非常早期的阶段
但是我我会觉得这是一个我自己个人
也是我认为下一代游戏引擎研发很关键的
很前沿的一个一个方向
所以在这边的课程的话呢
我也跟大家去点一下
让大家有点感觉
那基本上呢讲到这一节课的话呢
我们这个这一趴的东西基本上就讲完了
那现在的话呢
其实哎又到了我们又一个section对吧
就是四节课基本上结束的时候
也给大家布作业了
那么上一节首先我讲了上一节课的作业的
我们的时间还可以往后推
就同学们不要着急
其实我们并不认为
同学们需要把所有的作业做完
而且呢大家如果需要更多的时间
我们的我们的课程组的小伙伴
还有我们的很多共商观的小伙伴
其实他们真的很认真负责
大家都会很耐心地帮大家答疑解惑
给大家解决问题
那么接下来就讲我们这节课的作业是什么
其实讲完了整个工具体系啊
讲完了这些反射系统
我们有一个想法
就是说如果是同学们最想了解
最想掌握的呢是PULA这个小引擎对吧
那PILA小引擎呢
我觉得最核心的就是它的资产
包括同学问我说
为什么我们要自己的这个format
JASON这个format对吧
包括我们A做了这个自自动的
schema和反射系统
然后呢在我们的editor里面可以自动的去
那个就是说产生所有的编辑界面对吧
我们甚至做了一个小小的content browser
我们出现了旁边的property panel
所以呢我们这一期的作业呢
是一个开放性的命题
就是如果同学们知道了
这个反射系统这些东西的时候
我们希望我们这作业标题是这样
大家自己听好
就是大家可以尝试在我们的这个就是资产里面
asset里面定义一种自己的属性
比如说大家发现我们现在第一个机构对吧
我们知道它有read the body
他有他的mesh
它有它的animation
对不对
比如现在你想对这个世界做一点小小的逻辑
无论做什么都可以啊
比如说你希望这个角色会会是这个自动的打枪
或者有个血量对吧
比如说我想有个血量
我要增加它的血量的这样的一个一个属性
这样我从高处跳下来会摔死
打打个预防好
包括我从多高摔下来
我受到伤害是多少
这两个变量我想定义好好
那请尝试在皮克拉这个引擎里面
把这些属性增加到我们的这个
character的这个里面去
然后呢你可以在编辑源码
你可以编辑它
而且呢你一键点play的时候
这些属性真的能跟你的引擎代码起作用
当然因为现在我们的二次开发的接口
还没完全开放出来
所以你还需要直接改那个皮克拉的代码
没关系的
但是呢你至少从这个资产
从那个JASON的一个就是S的文件
到引擎内部的这个这个这个数据
到整个编辑器这条链路全部打通打通
那么如果这件事情大家做完的话
我们会认为大家就是真正掌握了
我们的这个就是说这套schema反射
asset编辑器的这套体系
这道题目其实是蛮开放的
那么当然了
我这边只给大家举个例子
比如血量这个例子对吧
其实同学们可以自由的发挥
就是你只要定义了你自己的cosmos的data
通过整个这套反射schema系统能够反射上来
同时的话在资产里面这个数据真的能读的
读的进来
存的出去
然后呢他真实的能产生游戏的game play的效果
那我们认为同学们这个作业就做完了
那同样的提交作业的方法呢也是老的方法
就是大家把自己的作业的思路
实现了代码和效果的截图展示出来
发给我们就好了
我们给大家帮助
给大家一些反馈
包括同学们有什么困难的话
我们的共商观也会帮大家来解决
好不好
Ok
那这一次是我们第一次
尝试做一个开放性的作业
因为这个作业我们本来我想做个三破
但是其实啊对于我们来讲
因为我们写了pk了
所以我们这个对我们很简单对吧
但是的话呢我相信对同学们来讲的话
一上来摸一摸它还是有些挑战好
那今天这就是我们课程的全部
能够给大家呈现我们的高质量内容
另外一个好像是这节课讲完之后
我们又可以休息一个星期了
对于我来讲的话
非常开心啊
我又可以过一个好的周末了
我们的小团队也可以过个好的周末好
那今天的课程全部在这儿
那接下来同学们有没有什么问题哦
对老规矩就是会出现我们的reference
就是那个把我们找的资料也给同学们去分享
好的
那同学们有没有什么问题对
就是刚才我们讲的
这次这个作业是比较开放的嘛
所以顺便补充一句啊
就是我们有一些更加详细的一些作业要求
我们会放到官网上
同学们有什么问题的话
随时可以问我们好
那同学们有没有什么问题
在线上可以问我们的呢
啊同学们
我们说小引擎的反射系统会输出详细的代码
讲解文档吗
哎这个东西啊
我们的课程组真的是在准备
可能会通过wiki的形式给大家
当然也有可能通过视频的形式看到
wicked的形式会更好
因为它的系统会更加的全面给大家
同学们
第二个问题很有意思
有同学问我说反射会不会影响运行效率
实际上的话呢
就反射对于引擎来讲没有什么影响
因为它本身那些反射代码你不用它
它不会产生任何的overhead
但是的话呢当你再去工具里面
去这个频繁的调用这些反射的代码
比如说get and set invoke
包括就是说因为在工具里面
很多时候
我们是通过字符串去找到那些函数的指针嘛
你要找那个map嘛
这个字符串根据字符串去search
当然我们可以把字符串优化成那个一个id
我们叫做string id的东西
我会反射
我会我的减速会更快一点
但是呢这个事情过程的话
本身有的时候会产生效率
特别是对于那种就是大批量的这些数据的
那个编辑
打个比方
比如说刚才我们讲的那个
就是刷草和植被的那个刷子
可能一下子它会创建很多的物体
很多物体属性都要被射一遍
包括我们在做sequencer的时候
我们要改变很多的parameter对吧
那这里面的话呢在编辑的时候
可能会有一些效率的影响
但是呢在run time的时候呢
这些数据还好不会影响
因为反射主要是在editing它会用到的东西
啊这个同学问的问题就比较挑战了
就是说在现在的游戏开发中
DCC工具和引擎工具之间的分工到底是什么
首先这个问题是非常大
也非常的难
因为呃说句实话
我自己现在有的时候也有一点点的晕
我跟大家讲一个两个有意思的一个发展方向
第一个就是说其实在现代的有那个DCC工具
比如说3D max maya
包括像ZBRUSH
包括像那个胡迪尼
其实越来越强大
真的他们很多时候都prefer
就是说诶
你能够在我的工具里面做尽可能多的东西
我甚至能提供一个类引擎RUNTIME的preview给你
你甚至可以把你的引擎集成进来
给我做一个viewer对吧
我可以让你做很多的view这个东西
那么这其实是DCD工具在五推的一个方向
但是的话呢
我又发现另外一个有意思的趋势是什么呢
就是说在现在一些前沿的引擎里面
我们希望把很多第四次的功能
直接集成到引擎里面来
那么这个原因是有是有很深的道理的
我举个简单的例子啊
比如说大家如果看虚幻五的发布中
有一个系统叫rain系统
那么也就是说我可以在引擎里面直接手K动画
大家知道就是我们以前在游戏已经教过
你的动画
是由max maya这些ADC的软件做的
对不对
但但是呢在我们实战的游戏研发中
我们会出现一个问题是什么呢
比如说我那边也场景中有一个啊
有一个这个这个这个比如说有个扶手
然后呢
我希望这个角色他是手抓着这个扶手跟你说话
诶那这个时候就很有意思了
就是说我怎么能做一个动画
让这个角色能够非常准确的抓住这个扶手呢
这件事情就很麻烦
那怎么办
传统做法是这样的
我们会把那个场景导成一个建模
导到3D max maya里面
因为这个模型本来就有嘛
对不对
好
我把那个角色放在
我想他放在那个位置
然后呢
让artist在max min里面精准的把那个手放上去
然后开始给你巴拉巴拉
开始说话
然后呢整个这个动画我再倒回到引擎里面去
我只要把角色的朝向位置大小全部对准之后
你可以看到在游戏的这个比如说过场动画里面
这个角色就能精准做这个操作
大家仔细想想
这个过程是不是特别的麻烦
是非常非常的痛苦
对不对
那么我们就会发现artist希望是说
既然你们的引擎工具做的那么强大了
你作为一个把这个角色首K1下
这个动画有什么难
我们想想好像也不难
确实我可以做啊
好那我们就干脆把这动画这盘也就做掉了
包括就是你会发现
比如说有些引擎
它会直接把一些DC的工具直接买进来
集成到达的体系里面去
所以说其实我看到的是什么呢
我很难讲两边在分家
我看到的是大量大量的融合
所以这个呢其实也是符合引擎作为一个生产力
工具的一个客观需求
就是说它实际上是以艺术家怎么方便怎么来
所以我个人也比较关注的一个方向
也就是说在引擎里面的话
怎么把这些DCC的功能直接集成到引擎里面来
这样减少artist在这个不同的工具之间
来回切换的痛苦
因为刚才大家看到我画的那张图
那张图是那个game engine architecture里面那张图吗
实际上我一直讲那个图是比较古老的嘛
就是它比较传统
事实上在每一个DC的工具
它的exporter importer数据来回倒一次的时候
就会产生一次呃
产生错误的这样的一个机会
包括会极大的下降我们的内容生产的效率
而且让整个内容生产变得更加的不直观
而且很容易出错
所以的话呢这个两边的融合
这个趋势现在特别的明显
所以你让我说哪个工具归d cc
哪个归我们的这个引擎的话
我认为这个边界是动态的
一直在变化好的
那今天的话就是再次谢谢大家
那我们争取在下一节课
我们再见
下节课
非常有意
Skin play
OK好拜拜
暑假愉快